all right welcome everybody we have
another white house coronavirus press
briefing which we are standing by for
this one we were told would be wondering
which we would get a presentation
presumably from doctors and not from
Donald Trump is my hope about the data
that they are using for the current
model that they believe is the most
accurate one meaning the model that
roughly suggests April 15th will be the
day that the virus peaks in the United
States now we have a whole bunch of data
about that already including from dr.
Christopher Murray so we're going to get
to that momentarily this press
conference today originally scheduled
for five p.m. Eastern which is 20
minutes from now Donald Trump tweeting
that it has been pushed to 5:15 p.m.
Eastern Time
we'll see when it actually happens but
I'll be here taking your questions and
going over with different things and so
the way I've been doing it is I take the
time before the press conference to
catch you up on like the last 24 hours
of coronavirus related news I take your
questions I take your comments we are
live on twitch Twitter YouTube as well
as Facebook so welcome to everybody who
is indeed watching today a big 24 hours
in coronavirus news and not a
particularly pleasant 24 hours every
24-hour period for the most part with
few exceptions worse than the prior 22
24 hour period and that's the way it's
going to be for for probably three weeks
at this point not even the peak the peak
itself expected to last about 10 or 12
days most likely you're just joining me
remember if you're watching on youtube
hit that like and subscribe button very
much appreciated make sure you're
following me if you're watching on
Twitch we will be getting questions and
comments via super chat so if you're
watching on YouTube super chats will
show up in that bottom left window kwb
for example saying looks like the upside
down sandwich eating blowback is really
weighing heavily on you are you okay but
oh I'm doing fine I just went for a walk
and it's really windy out that's why my
hair is a little bit uh oh boy it's like
I've almost got with these weird Tufts
it's a little wacky but no I'm come
lately fine it's just really really
windy outside and I ran in and started
the stream that's that's all that's
going on
I appreciate the cheer from motion
design on Twitch sending me a hundred
bits to buy a comb I don't know how much
a comb costs cuz I've had the same comb
for like 15 years now but uh I assume
it's more than a dollar that's my guess
at this point in time Ollie says this
briefing is brought to you by my pillow
and God yeah I have the my pillow clip
which we can look at Oh actually I don't
I have a couple of different we have a
bunch of stuff to look at we'll get to
it momentarily okay let's get updated
with the latest numbers okay the latest
numbers official numbers of course are
that let's refresh we are now at eight
hundred and forty nine thousand official
cases and forty-one thousand six twenty
five official deaths we'll look at the
united states numbers momentarily of
course remember that these numbers the
case numbers drastically understating
the real number of cases many people
still are not being tested we have the
we are number one in the United States
we have the most official cases we don't
have the most deaths and Italy still
just in deeper and deeper trouble eight
hundred people a day are dying in Italy
and when we talk about you know the peak
is not one day it's important to look at
Italy's data Italy arguably peaked ten
days ago and since March 21st
they've just been hovering around this
eight hundred deaths per day number when
I talk about the peak will likely last
ten to twelve days in the US this is
what I'm talking about and our numbers
projected to be worse projected to be
about 22 hundred deaths a day during our
12 day peak but I will get to that
momentarily so those are the numbers so
far yesterday in the United States
20,000 new cases 558 new deaths today so
far 19,000 new cases 546 deaths so we're
basically where we were yesterday except
there's still seven more than seven
hours left of the day so today is going
to be the worst day
let's now look at a state-by-state 180
Willits refresh actually okay in just
what we've been talking we found two
thousand new cases here in the US just
like that
one hundred and eighty-three almost
hundred and eighty four thousand
official cases in the US so two things
about the case number on the one hand
this number still doesn't reflect the
real number of cases because a lot of
people aren't being tested on the other
hand as we process the backlog of tests
you know all those people who were
tested a week ago and said I'm told it's
gonna take seven eight nine days to get
my test results we are now processing
more than just the 20 last 24 hours
worth of tests so the new case numbers
may also be overestimating the number of
new cases some of the people who are
showing up today were tested seven days
ago and started showing symptoms
5 to 7 days before that so some of these
case numbers like if i refresh again
okay it hasn't been updated but some of
these case numbers are cases from
mid-march that's just the way it works
3700 deaths there is now a right-wing
movement arguing that the death number
is over exaggerated I'll explain that to
you momentarily and then an updated look
at the model from dr. Christopher Murray
who we are very actively trying to get
on the program because his model is
excellent and we want to interview him
as soon as possible the estimate for the
peak in the United States continues to
be April 15 okay now understand that
this will come much later in some states
and earlier isn't earlier than others if
you look at California it's expected to
be 12 days later not until April 27th if
you look at New York for example the
peak is expected to be April 9th about
six days earlier than national but for
now we'll just look at the national
numbers when you look at the death toll
we are now estimated to be 14 days from
the death peak the website is kovat 19
dot health data org but this is the
really important thing I want people to
understand if april 15th is the peak
that's the day on which we are expecting
again it's a range but the midpoint
would be 2214 deaths on the peak if you
look at the day before it's almost the
same number it's 22:08 deaths if you
look at the day after it's 22:05 deaths
so understand that when we say the peak
we're really talking about a period
probably from about April 9th where
we'll have 1,900 deaths all the way up
until April 26 so the peak will last two
weeks is the point I'm trying to make
and if you want to look at so today we
are 15 days from the peak if you look at
April thirtieth which would be 15 days
after the peak we're still expecting
more than 1500 people to die on that day
these are tragic horrible numbers all
right
understand that again I see people
asking the site is kovat 19 dot health
data org in terms of total deaths every
day the model is adjusted so the model
has data up until yesterday then it
becomes a dotted line which are
estimates the the yellow blob here is
the confidence interval so right now the
estimate for deaths in this wave note
that this goes only until August 3rd or
4th there could be another wave in the
fall and another wave in 2021 the
estimate for this wave is 8 3 9 67 so
here's what I want people to understand
because a lot of people are already
talking about when can we get back to
work and all of that stuff so far we've
had 37 20 deaths the best estimate is 4
8 3 9 6 7 ok we're still waiting on 95%
of the deaths this is what you know
people are already talking about we're
getting past it and we're on we're soon
gonna be past the peak because of this
is a virus the word viral comes from
this okay we're still waiting on
ninety-five point five seven percent of
the deaths even though we've been we've
been doing this for weeks and it's
already very very bad so that's that's
where the data is right now and I'll
report this to you daily before the
press conference is to keep ourselves
updated let me say thank you and welcome
to everybody joining us for today's
corona virus press conference from the
White House
dr. Burks said that today is the day
where she or someone is going to go into
detail with a presentation about the
modeling they are currently looking at
the best modeling now dr. Burks already
said she's looking very closely at this
model this is Christopher Murray's model
so I wouldn't be surprised to see her
put similar data up on the screen when
this starts it will of course be
bookended by hyperbole lies and
self-congratulations by donald trump but
we've just got to deal with that too to
get to the doctors I do want to mention
if you are so I know there's a lot of
people in our audience we're actually
gonna do a survey soon to see how much
of our audience currently is being
affected monetarily by the virus but one
thing I want to mention is if you are in
a position to be able to grab a
membership it's a couple bucks a month
if you pay monthly or yearly on our
website join pakman.com please consider
doing it we are in an increasingly tough
spot where we are down about 3540
percent in YouTube revenue because of
the virus and advertisers just bailing
we've lost two major advertisers that
work with us directly so I get
everybody's tightening the belt a lot of
people are canceling memberships I get
it trust we're all trying to weather
this if you are someone who is in a
position to be able to grab a membership
on our website I can't think of a more
important time to do it and we do have
this coupon code 2020 now which saves
you 66% I don't want your last dollar
we're all in this together right we're
all going to have to sort of tighten the
belt weather the storm and hopefully
come out of this on the other side but I
do appreciate everybody who has been
grabbing memberships during the streams
because it is it's what's we're pushing
against it's a balance right we've got a
bunch of stuff pressing down people
canceling all that stuff and folks who
have been signing up have really been
keeping us going so join pakman.com is
the place to do that let me say thanks
to Lil's Dorsey - who's subscribed with
twitch prime Frisky seal has subscribed
and says if everybody is staying home
where are the new deaths coming from a
couple things to understand number
not everybody is staying home number two
it takes on average about 17 days to die
as morose as that is so a lot of today's
deaths are cases that started showing
symptoms 17 days ago and may have caught
it anywhere from 1 to 14 days before
that so there's a very big delayed
effect in when people are dying relative
to when they they were infected I guess
is the term that that I'm looking for
okay let me answer some super chats rose
to Parker says 30% increase in cases in
Louisiana last night yep it that's why
we call it a virus and you know all
these claims about hey places with a
hundred people don't have to word case
is don't have to worry well 100 becomes
three hundred three hundred becomes a
thousand next thing you know you've got
three or four thousand cases and people
start dying it's it's viral this is
where the term comes from and Trump
visibly confused by it very very often
Brody says David it's getting worse in
gallus I am scared hearing from a lot of
viewers in Dallas saying the same
essential says the ia hme model is
looking pretty accurate now yeah that's
why I keep referring to it and every day
it's fine-tuned so yesterday the death
estimate was like eighty two thousand
now it's closer to eighty for every day
this is updated with the best data I
believe it's the best model that we
currently have
Walker Anderson says would you deviate
from orange man bad to real reporting if
it was your sister that reported the
Democratic president nominee of unwanted
penetration you know orange man bad is
is a completely delusional way to
distract from the fact that we have
arguably close to the worst response
globally to the virus so we're not gonna
fall for nonsense
Marcus ever Ling says has there ever
been any guidance on how people without
insurance should get tested and get
treatment there has not there is not and
you know we hear about co-pays are being
waived for the insurance you have at the
state level we're hearing guidance on
people without insurance but that
depends on which state you live in so
the answer is essentially now Charlie
says regulators have still not taken
down David's excessive and probably
illegal 66 percent off coupon yeah you
know this is this is actually crazy
because regulators are trying to take
down and cease and desist coronavirus
toothpaste and all of this BS they've
not come after me for offering a 66%
discount and I'm lucky because this
discount in some southern states that
discount would be illegal it's legal to
marry certain cousins in some of these
states and a 66% discount would be
illegal because it's just too big of a
discount so my advice to you is take
advantage of it why not go to join
pakman.com and use that coupon code this
20 20 now 20 20 now is the coupon code
okay let me say thanks to motion design
and I read my Tharin as well as AB nerd
herb astrophysical dry mal bla all who
grabbed twitch prime subscriptions okay
a couple other things I wanted to go
over with you oh not that that's just my
Twitter okay let me give you so this is
a minute from yesterday now initially
when I watched this yesterday Trump was
confronted by the great reporter Yami SH
Alcindor about how per capita hello we
are not actually testing more than
places like South Korea at first I
thought Trump was gaslighting her but I
actually after watching this a couple of
times
I don't think Trump knows what per
capita means let's watch it together and
see if we can figure it out
mr. president you said several times
that the United Sates is ramped up
testing but the United States is still
not testing per capita as many red as
many people as other countries like
South Korea why is that and when do you
think that that number will be on par
with other countries it's very much in
part okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna
actually do this piece by piece when
Trump says it's on par with South Korea
that's a lie per capita carruth Korea
has 50
million people we have 340 right it's
not on par per capita we have areas of
country that's very knows so we have
areas of country that's very I guess
he's talking about rural but the idiocy
of that is per capita accounts for the
fact that you have dense areas and rural
areas so rural doesn't matter the point
is what's the per capita testing rate
South Korea better than anybody I know
South Korea better than anybody that's
also a lie in case anybody was wondering
it's a very tight you know how many
people are in Seoul yeah you know big
the city of Seoul is 38 million people
so that's a lie Seoul Korea is at 38
meters of elevation so that's the only
38 M I could find related to South Korea
to Seoul but that's not true Seoul has
about nine million people the Metro has
about 25 million the country has 51
million so that's also a lie that's
bigger than anything we have 38 million
people all tightly wound together people
are tightly wound which that's also a
lie by the way nobody's wound we have
vast farmlands we have vast areas where
they don't have much of a problem right
so again when we talk about per capita a
lot of the states that have few cases
have a high per capita California has
many cases their per capita is not that
high when you consider they have 30
million people anyway I came away from
this believing that Trump doesn't
actually know what per capita means that
that's my takeaway I don't believe he
was gaslighting you Miche I believe that
he actually just doesn't know what ker
per capita means let me know your
opinion about that let me say a few
thank-yous okay let me thank Jonathan
Henson Jonathan is new member number one
today at join pakman.com Thank You
Jonathan fight the power David Sachs is
new member number two today at join
pakman.com Reza takhtee is new member
number three today at join pakman.com
let me say thanks to Tyler Hitchcock
who's new member number four at join
pakman.com Adam creamin is new member
number five at join pakman.com Rhonda
frolf is new member number six
at join pakman.com Gerard McNeil comes
in at number 7 lucky 7 Gerard McNeil
also want to say thanks to oh wait a
second Tyler did you sign up twice Tyler
seems to have signed up twice you know
what we're gonna count it it counts
twice because it's two memberships even
if one of them was a mistake Tyler we'll
deal with that later or there's - Tyler
hitchcock's I don't know number 8
continuing Nik Ferreira is new member
number 9 at join pakman.com Katherine
Erikson is new member number 10 Ola
Kristofferson is new member number 11
today andrew way Lorne is new member
number 12 and yes some of those
pronunciations may not have been spot-on
I am I am always doing the best I can
with with the pronunciations okay let's
get to a few other super chats here
waffles derp awful says you averaged you
need averaged case death data to
identify change yeah well you also need
to be looking at the growth factor the
growth factor is the other element
element of data that's important Craig
Wow says do you think Jesse Lee Peterson
believes that the coronavirus was
created to impeach Trump you know I have
hung out with him in person he seems to
not be playing a character on his show
so he probably I don't know what he's
been saying I don't watch his show but
he probably does believe whatever it is
he's been saying publicly when I met him
in private and was on his show I had
every indication that he believed
everything that he said which is scary
it's very very scary remember if you're
watching on YouTube hit that like button
and hit that as Trump would say hit that
subscribe button as well that's a two
very very important buttons like and
subscribe Joseph din Z's asks will red
states be worse than expected since they
are not doing anything if they open up
sooner will it cause a resurgence of
kovat 19 yeah you know at this point my
my assessment of what Trump is doing is
he's trying to calculate he wants to
the needle Trump wants to calculate a
Jesus like resurrection of the of the
economy so that he can get the political
benefit but delay the second wave of
infection until after November 6th it's
the sixth the Election Day earlier that
first day in November with the election
that's my impression of what Donald
Trump is trying to do and yes the the
resurgence is a concern and doctor foul
Qi pointed it out and said we are
expecting a Trump said hopefully not and
immediately yesterday doctor foul she
said there will be a secondary outbreak
the question is how big will it be and
will we have any any therapeutic tools
available by that point in time a Jammu
o male a Jammu is here almost every
single stream I really appreciate you
being here
a Jammu a John who says the fact that
Trump asks someone in the industry if
the hospitals are backdooring instead of
trusting the medical experts is the most
glaring proof that he's focused on money
instead of life of course
Joseph van Scoy says heard Chris Cuomo
got kovat wish him well one of the few
great journalists left you know you're
doing something right when both sides
hate you I like Chris Cuomo yeah and
very sad that he got it he seems to have
a mild enough case for now that he is
going to keep working for the time being
which is which is I mean if it's a mild
case that's good that's a good thing
Derek Vandervoort says can Falwell be
sued for reopening Liberty University if
so should he himself be sued or the
university I hope the answer is yes and
I would say both but I'm not a lawyer
max Daniels and Peter Walker have
grabbed youtube memberships kwb says can
I steal hyperbole lies in
self-congratulation for my next album
named by all means have at it just thank
me in the liner notes Carrie wesp says
any news on how Trump's hotel employees
are doing no I was looking for that
today and I don't know I don't know the
answer to that here we got a bunch of
these at once and they scrolled up
Bamber Katie says thank you for doing
what you do your streams are informative
down-to-earth and comforting even when
the news is bad thank you I so
appreciate that cacus Umbra says EPA
rule changes increasing depreciation tax
withholding avoiding oversight with
signing statements all while the world
is distracted covered a bunch of that
stuff on my broadcast show today I would
if you guys are into podcasts please be
aware that there is a david pakman show
podcast an audio podcast i would love it
if you subscribe that's our long-form
our daily show and even if you don't
listen to the podcast even if you watch
on YouTube or twitch or Facebook
subscribe to it because it helps our
numbers if they for no other reason than
that but a lot of the stuff like the EPA
rules we cover on the podcast than we
did today Oklahoma has subscribed on
YouTube Forrest rice says Trump turned
my family into conspiracy theorists
that's very sad very very sad
Alonzo Cal Poly Pomona says harrogate
plot twist
David is a wizard all right Reese's
Pieces oh I see what you did there I
have been watching these live streams
every day so I'd figured I'd chip in
what I can thank you and listen very
importantly this stream is for everybody
we've had as many as 12 13 thousand
people across all of our platforms on
these streams lately and you know even
if you can't support vyas that the
stream is for everybody please do hit
the like button though if you're
watching on youtube that's free you can
start smashing that like button
you do need to close the live chat
window if you're on Android to see that
like button like and subscribe costs
nothing and it really helps us to
trigger YouTube into recommending this
stream over others let me say thank you
to Heather Farnham Heather as new member
number 13 today at join pakman.com and
Heather drain - Heather's signing up
back-to-back Thank You Heather and
Heather very much appreciate that
grab a membership at join pakman.com we
are sadly so we've decentralized
production of the show we've upgraded
producer Pat's home internet so he can
be editing the show from home we've done
all that stuff but sadly YouTube revenue
is down about 3540 percent because of
the virus and a lot of people are having
to cancel memberships because they're
laid off so whoever can support us
through our website join pakman.com we
so appreciate it and I'm going to have
an update about our apron to April
membership numbers probably tomorrow
might take me until April 2nd to fully
characterize those data and I will come
to you with that information but in the
meantime we do have this coupon code
20/20 now you save 66% and well I mean I
guess mostly it's just good for you you
save 66% we give the discount but it's a
good thing it's a good thing for
everybody let me say thank you to let's
see here
the FEM geek has sat assigned up with
twitch prime Jude upski is a new twitch
subscriber yes 79 has subscribed with
prime silo 10 subscribed and says David
my wife and I listen to you to get some
sanity in our lives thank you thank you
silo appreciate that goofy the psycho
has also just gifted 5 subscriptions on
twitch very very big deal mmm big deal
happening there ok other super chats
that are coming in Christy says latest
from Mitch McConnell is the impeachment
caused kovat 19 seriousness to be missed
I saw that guy's a complete tool I mean
it's it's crazy he he is an effective
tool he's an operator for the Republican
Party but he's a disgusting just
disgusting guy let's see here choco
flavored cookies says hey David orange
man bad equals re real and true that's
right I mean he's terrible he's terrible
it's not it's not a meme it's just the
reality we are waiting for the start of
the press conference originally
scheduled for 5:15 I'm sorry for 5:00
and pushed to 5:15
I'm trying to see if we have any live
video of what's going on both of these
feeds the c-span feed and the PBS feed
oh no this yes the c-span speed feed and
the PBS feed do not have any live video
if someone knows whether they whether
any feed is currently live in the in the
room or you know in the Rose Garden let
me know we usually like switching over
to that but right now I am not seeing
that anybody is live yet which could be
a sign yeah Fox News I don't want to
pick up that's ideally one of the sort
of online like Washington Post doesn't
seem to have it oh here we go
ah there we go so we are back indoors
today very good we've got John Roberts
appear and we've got photographers and a
lot of elements of journalism are in the
room
very good okay so we've solved the
problem Chris Davidson says when are you
going to run for office we need you in
the game keep it up you know I don't
know that I want the oversight that
comes with being an elected official and
running a campaign that's a big you know
I like to operate in the shadows so to
speak next thing you know I'll be
audited Fuzion says why do you look like
you have not taken a shower in two weeks
oh because I haven't yeah my look
reflects that accurately no I was just
out walking around and it was just very
windy that's all zero elements of
reality says hi David had a fight with
your hair today
tam I am subscribed to YouTube and also
at join pakman.com I appreciate you for
covering this thank you love your wind
hair yeah I mean I'm very much overdue
for a haircut even the side is getting
close to 6 inches long I mean look at
this this is crazy right I mean this is
this is illegal in some some some
countries but it is what it is because
of as you know we are we are all home
Joseph Herrera says David religious
leaders keep calling the flock to
congregate and breathe on each other
it's reckless endangerment it is and a
pastor has now been arrested for it in
Florida and they need to keep arresting
them and hopefully they will Lee Verrett
says do you think when Trump talks about
per capita he means per capital
oh that's interesting maybe Trump met
maybe maybe Trump thought per-capita
meant like in the capital city that's
that's a good one pair tieran says I
prefer to pay membership than to marry a
cousin but then again I'm not from the
southern United States fair fair point
pair Anthony Lowe's ago with a $50 super
chat says unfortunately models predict a
double peak with the second around 90
percent of the first I predict a false
all clear around June 1 then this all
over again third week of July ramping
back up second peak third week of
September that is what a lot of the
models are suggesting and I would not be
surprised to see that Anthony you have
indeed been following some of these good
reports it sounds like Christian Hansen
says would you ever do a discussion with
destiny again sure yeah I would do it
duffle bag spouse travels says
confounded on how many people think
Trump is doing a good job and are
listening to what he says
I've lived in SK for seven years and he
knows absolutely nothing about the
country o South Korea yeah plagued Docs
says the hairdo is worth 5 bucks Bernie
solidarity lol Ian says what's your
favorite Led Zeppelin song fool in the
rain I think my favorite is fool in the
rain followed by maybe good times bad
times those are probably some of my -
two of my favorite Zeppelin songs at
this point in time let me say thank you
to some other really great people
Terry Fultz is new member number 15
today at join pakman.com Thank You Terry
I really appreciate your support at what
is a tough time for independent media
Aaron Carlson is new member number 16
today Elisha Hassan or Hassan is new
member number 17 today at join
pakman.com Warren Pagal is new member
number 18 today I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly I see it like bagel but
with a P so that's why I'm saying Warren
Pagal Karin Linus is new member number
19 today at join pakman.com also want to
say thanks to David Hudgens who is new
member
number twenty today at join pakman.com
really appreciate it please consider
yourself invited
we've been streaming daily I did take a
Friday and Saturday off from the streams
for a mental health break but otherwise
we've been streaming daily sometimes
twice daily keeping up with all the news
Plus doing the Daily Show and folks who
have been supporting us at join
pakman.com or extraordinarily
appreciated want to say thanks on twitch
to general Anubis general Anubis
subscribed with prime and also want to
say thanks to the 4200 folks watching on
YouTube so appreciate you guys I think
we we P speaking of peaks I think our
peak total audience for the streams was
maybe maybe it was Sunday or Monday wait
today's Tuesday no it must have been
Sunday then I think we had about twelve
or thirteen thousand total across our
four platforms which is amazing and
again these are not ratings for people
that are entertained by Trump the way
Trump says people are scared people are
increasingly staying home and when the
president speaks they want to hear
something they want to hear it words of
comfort they want to hear words that
suggest he knows what's going on we
don't get it we certainly don't get it
but that is why so many people are
watching these because we're all hoping
for something that will not strike us as
depraved lies from the president of the
United States
Ian says did you know Eric Andre watches
your show I did not have if any if
that's for real I know sometimes people
troll me they like love for me to think
someone watches my show who doesn't if
you know that for a fact
please email me somehow what you know
about that or somebody let me know I
think once he liked or retweeted
something I posted but I I didn't know
that Eric Andre watched watched the show
I actually there are some people who are
not publicly political who are very well
known who privately have told me they
watch my youtube channel every day and I
think it would be really cool to talk
about who they are but I'm not going to
do it because there
they're kind of a political publicly but
if any if that's true if the Eric Andre
thing is true please do email me and let
me know let me know what's going on as
people continue to file in here we
should soon be underway Donna Williams
OOP sorry hold on a second where did
that go Donna Williams says thank you
for covering these disgusting so-called
press conferences I can't watch them
without you thank you I I couldn't do it
without you guys it'd be I mean I could
but it'd be just me and with a mic in a
dark room it'd be weird David wills says
I hid the baking stage of quarantine
have you started making bread and
cookies from scratch yet yes I may let
me recommend listen I'm gonna go into
this is gonna be a little too semitic
for some people okay as you know I I am
extremely Jewish culturally culturally
okay on Sunday I baked tahini cookies
okay you understand what I'm saying here
I don't know if some of you guys are
familiar with the lovely sesame treat
called halva okay calva is a sort of
mushed up sessom sweetened sesame paste
sometimes it's chocolate covered
sometimes it's marbled with chocolate
sometimes it's got pistachio okay halva
is delicious tahini is also a different
type of sesame paste and it interrupted
me by the way if people don't like this
tahini cookies it's a butter it's sort
of a shortbread cookie with butter that
has tahini in it it almost has the
flavor of halva but it is a shortbread
cookie consistency you put a little
pistachio crumble on top and a little
cinnamon this is one of the best cookies
that I've had and I did indeed bake
those on Sunday they're fantastic a lot
of people are bailing oh I should get
off of the topic of halva right away
because we're about to miss Rooke we're
about to see a lot of people bail okay a
rich rope a thak says is great guy Chris
Cuomo's bro a bit corrupt isn't all
isn't every major
politician a little bit corrupt come on
Matt says the website keeps giving
database errors when trying to sign up
hopefully that is everyone signing up
yes our website is being overrun by
incredibly good people who are signing
up for memberships but they are
continuing to come through so keep
trying folks that's my advice let me say
thanks to Andy Smith who is new member
number 21 today at join pakman.com Linda
Plaza is new member number 22 today at
join pakman.com Jennifer Shah is new
member number 23 and Taylor Netherland
is new member number 24 today at join
pakman.com one more and we will be at
our initial goal of 25 look at that look
at that that's solid could this guy get
out of the way
I really prefer to see what's going on
at the front there we go Wow oh now he's
standing even closer to the camera dear
God could if he could sit down it would
really be good for me okay
let me sit and say thank you to Mike
pics for subscribing with Prime and
Najib who subscribed with prime Greg
Williams has grabbed the YouTube
membership so has Mike Henderson pair
tieran has said have you seen the horror
that is happening in sure in Hungary
scares me more than corona you know I
have to admit I have not I have not I
will look that up people asking what
I've been reading lately I am 10 pages
from finishing the book new jack by Ted
Conover Ted Conover is an investigative
journalist who actually became a
correctional officer at sing-sing prison
in New York in order to write a book
about correctional officers fantastic
book fantastic book highly recommended
and I recommended it to folks recently
on the broadcast show zero the liger
away sorry Andria Hertz grabbed a soy
boy membership zero the liger says the
USPS is at risk of closing by June I
didn't hear that but I've been reading a
lot about what's going on with the
the post-office and it's not good mascot
or ma Scot says how is YouTube revenue
down when they can't handle the traffic
from the numbers of people watching so
here's what you have to understand
YouTube revenue is not based on views
alone YouTube revenue is based on how
much did advertisers pay for ads so
imagine that a lot of advertisers want
at to buy ads on YouTube it's an auction
system so the price of an ad gets bid up
I get I think it's like fifty five
percent right so if the price gets bit
up my fifty five percent is a lot more
tons of youtube advertisers are
realizing nobody's buying [ __ ] during
this crisis so we are gonna stop
advertising on YouTube that means the
YouTube ad rates are no longer bid up
that's how we're down 35% viewership is
steady and maybe even up a little bit
but we're making 35% less off of that
number because the ad rates are not
being bid up all YouTube all Google ad
programs work on a bidding system so you
know when you search for dentist in my
area or whatever if a lot of dentists
are trying to show up in the sponsored
links when you do a google search they
probably have to pay more because it is
getting bid up same system on YouTube
that's why we're down about 3540 percent
okay abled Yves says David thank you for
all you do my question has your opinion
of Bernie's viability as the nominee
changed over the past couple of weeks
listen I I believe that if Biden doesn't
step down died or literally become
comatose I don't think that it's going
to change but those are the three
scenarios where it could a green lover
and Jessica neckman have grabbed YouTube
membership so people are talking about
my expression yesterday during the my
pillow moment yeah somebody actually
filmed it this is really funny here was
somebody who was watching along with me
during the my pillow segment this is so
funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay anyway so that was yesterday we'll
see if it's any crazier we'll see if
it's any crazier today when things when
things get going
okay let me say a few other thank-yous
let me see here okay
uh hold on a second I want to say thanks
to Maureen Kelly who is indeed new
member number 25 today let's go for 50
we've not achieved it on any of these
streams so far Vanessa
tah is new I like that last name tah ta
Vanessa tah is new member number 26
today Christian bear is new member
number 27 okay hold on a second now I've
got a things are getting crazy Rob from
Arizona is new member number 28 at join
pakman.com hey Co Gunther is new member
number 29 thank you Paul Brunel is new
member number 30 on my website
Stacy Peters is new member number 31
Manuel cell is that a silent G is it
just cell is new member number 32 today
and Matthew Standish is new member
number 33 I really appreciate that
oh and hold on I think I've got one
other person to thank here yes
Sam Patel Sam Patel is new member number
34 today at join pakman.com remember if
you're just joining us on YouTube twitch
Twitter and Facebook we are standing by
for the previously scheduled for five
p.m. Eastern press conference
rescheduled for 5:15 and now five
minutes late we were told that today is
the day
where they would they doctors I guess
probably dr. Burks who is is or is not
questionable dr. Burks is going to show
us where the data from their model for
the April 15 peak comes from now we
already think we know this is the
Christopher Murray model again this is
kovat 19 dot health data org let me
refresh it in case it has changed it is
not which estimates the peak being a
roughly two week period centered around
April 15 we will get to some pretty
hellish numbers within about five or six
days and those will last until I mean
really into May with a total death toll
for wave one of the virus of about
84,000 we believe this is the model dr.
Burks is now most closely looking at so
we'll see that did it we were told today
we would get that case made okay Jessica
Mecca Minh I think I already think
Jessica and green lover waffles der
awful says there's toilet paper
available again in Germany glad to hear
it
kwb says use this super chat to buy
elements of self grooming TR Mason says
David its elements of blank adjective
not elements of noun well I think it
could be used both ways
Raymond Allen says watching from Austin
Texas keep up the amazing work and hair
Alejandra Levine says what do you think
about the whole Andrew Cuomo cult of
personality on both sides that's forming
he just blocked 9 billion in aid to New
York yeah the the Andrew Cuomo I'm gonna
talk about the Andrew Cuomo thing
tomorrow but listen he's mostly handling
this crisis well he's also a sort of
centrist Democrat who does things that
actual progressives don't like it's the
contradiction that we've seen for a long
time a lot of times good center-left
Democratic leaders put out a good sort
of optics but are doing things we don't
like it's not uncommon Barack Obama
falls under that umbrella many many
people okay
people asking again about the website
for that model the website is Co vid 19
dot health data dot on YouTube do me
this tiny teeny teeny teeny small favor
of making sure you like the live stream
on YouTube and hit the subscribe button
both are free both really help us out
this is the time the ten minutes before
they start is like the time to like the
stream because then all sorts of people
come in we're actually we're gonna
probably set up a survey soon where we
are curious how many people that are
watching the press briefings are people
already subscribed to our channel vs.
how many people are just stumbling
across our channel looking for the press
briefing we might do a little like a
three question survey related to that
tomorrow because it might help us to
tailor some of the different content
that we're doing and and sort of that
sort of thing Eileen are Ward says I
love the elements of the David Pakman
show very nice
Joseph Dizzy's says will there be an
even bigger crash that will turn into a
depression in April people will fail to
pay loans and all of the instability
will show that's a major concern and we
don't know the answer but it certainly
may happen Gregg Williams says your hair
dealt with it better than Trump's
yesterday yeah Trump was dealing with
the wind yesterday as well people
wondering why my hair looks like this I
was just out for a walk oh my god this
is just crazy I was just out for a walk
and it's just really windy in Boston
that's all it was a socially responsible
walk Donna Williams says tried to send a
super check yesterday but it wouldn't go
through others had trouble as well
unfortunately we have no real control
over the super chat system so I
apologize for that millennial cooking
corner has grabbed a youtube
subscription where did that go there it
is Jessica McMinn says why are Trump and
Penn still allowed to be inside the same
room yeah you would think they would be
keeping them separate at this point sort
of like the designated survivor thing on
a State of the Union address days let me
say a big beautiful very strong
thank you to Jack Donovan who is
subscriber number 35 on my website join
pakman.com Jose Bruna is number 36 today
at join pakman.com also want to say
thank you to Mary Ann damiana who is new
member number 3 737 today at join
pakman.com have has anybody heard who
the White House reporter who tested
positive for the viruses cuz there's a
few people who have been missing since
that announcement was made I don't think
I've seen CNN's caitlin collins in the
room it's been a different CNN reporter
that trump has been arguing with the oen
person was swapped out i believe no no I
know Chris Cuomo has it but I'm talking
about someone in the room who last week
they said who was normally at these
briefings has the virus I don't know if
we've we figured out who that is no not
Cuomo I'm not talking about Cuomo was
not a White House correspondent who it
was normally in the room cup one person
saying it is Caitlin Collins I've not
heard that but I don't I just noticed
she and the Oh a n person have been have
been gone maybe we don't know yet maybe
it's not been said Rachel Robinson says
as individuals stuck home social
distancing what can we do to help the
crisis you're doing it you're staying
home my loved ones and I feel helpless
want to know what more we can do listen
if you have if you have supplies to
donate to a local hospital you can do
that if you can just convince others to
stay home that's something you can do
but this is a weird thing because the
best way to help is by not doing
anything it's by staying home it's
limiting trips to the grocery store
limiting your interactions with people
and trying to trying to slow the spread
that's that's what it is
Madelyn lensing grabs a youtube
subscription Adam Waddington says I
admired the height of your hair take my
money it is just by force of gravity
starting to calm down on its own that's
interesting
Rick Hernandez says your hair your hair
bro Craig says where's Biden what does
he think of the response what would his
plan be he is missing an opportunity to
show he's a leader
you know when he has spoken publicly
it's not been the best you know so I
think that that's probably part of why
we're not seeing that much of him your
lawyer has grabbed a YouTube
subscription gesture speed says David
longtime fan from Canada first-time
donor
have you watched PM Trudeau speaking to
Canadians yeah I mean listen Trudeau has
been very good Merkel's been good
McCrone has been good even you know
Boris Johnson and the Argentinian
president neither of whom I am sort of
like politically aligned with who I
support as politicians they've been
better than Trump I don't know of anyone
who's been worse than Trump I mean I
don't know what's been going on in like
Iran or China or Saudi Arabia but
everybody that I've watched has been far
better than Donald Trump
Casey O'Connell says David's expression
when the my pillow guy was talking
yesterday is worth a donation thank you
thanks to Mike Barton and wicked insane
Dustin DPS says TYT says Cuomo might
replace Biden how I have no idea so
that's why I'm not doing any any stories
like that I don't know what argument TYT
is making for that but you know I am NOT
saying that that is likely to happen
because I don't see the likely path I am
seeing the messages and chat from people
saying the website is down it is working
for me right now I think a lot of people
are trying to sign up keep trying keep
trying dr. Anthony foul he is here he
often does that thing where he kind of
holds his hands in what looks like a
sort of prayer pose right when he comes
out dr. Burks also came out and she is
off-screen to our right - Anthony foul
she's left it looks like we are getting
close to the start of this press
conference again expecting today to see
the model and data that they are using
to predict the peak on April 15 let me
say a few other thank-yous Kim Han ritzy
is new member number 38 today at join
pakman.com thanks Kim Brandon Taylor is
new member number 39 Chris LeBlanc
new member number forty and okay alright
a guy who signed up with the name Joey
salads but I know it's really Trey I'll
say it Joey salads thanks for the
membership I know it's not really Joey
but Trey thank you for the membership
and you know you as long as as long as
the check clears
use whatever name you want that's that's
my take on it let's see here J Harper
says have have you seen the sexual
assault allegation against Biden what
are your thoughts about the news I'm
gonna be doing an extensive coverage of
that so I don't want it just kind of
like spit ball it here because I think
it requires responsibility and you know
being thorough it's me John B says does
having YouTube premium negatively affect
your revenue I don't think so we just
get a cut of your premium monthly
payment all right here's Trump and pence
we've got foul Qi and Burks let's listen
thank you oh my god it's so low our
country is in the midst of a great
national trial unlike any we have ever
faced before oh my god you all see it
you see it probably better than most
let's just see if the volume level is
better here it might be better will be
three five seconds behind but we might
be better off guys give me a second
[Music]
thank you this is better yeah it's up
all the way our country is in the midst
of a great national trial unlike any we
have ever faced before you all see it
you see it probably better than most
word war with a deadly virus success in
this fight will require the full
absolute measure of our collective
strength love and devotion very
important love each of us has the power
through our own choices and actions to
save American lives and rescue the most
vulnerable among us that's why we really
have to do what we all know is right
every citizen is being called upon to
make sacrifices
every business is being asked to fulfill
its patriotic duty every community is
this is literal war language now pay
attention to how we live work and
interact each and every day and I
wouldn't be surprised to see this going
on long into the future when this virus
is gone and defeated some of the things
we're doing now will be very good
practice for the future including for
not getting the flu which is very
devastating also so some of what we're
learning now will live on into the
future I really believe that shaking
hands or not shaking hands washing hands
all the time staying a little apart 15
days ago we published our nationwide
guidelines to slow the spread of the
virus on Sunday I announced that this
campaign will be extended until April
30th
in a few moments dr. Burks will explain
the data yes that formed the basis for
our decision to extend the guidelines
and dr. Fauci will explain why it's
absolutely critical for the American
people to follow the guidelines for the
next 30 days it's a matter of life and
death it's frankly it's a matter of life
and death I know our citizens will rise
to the occasion and they already have
sacrificed a lot we had the greatest
economy in the history of our country
we're the greatest economy in the world
we had the best unemployment numbers and
employment numbers that we've ever had
by far and in one instant we said we
have no choice but to close it up just
as Americans have always done they will
do a job like few have seen before and
they're proud to do it I see that
there's a great pride going on right to
him
before we hear from our experts we have
a few other announcements today the
Treasury Department and Small Business
Administration announced further details
on the
paycheck protection program which was
made possible by the 2 trillion dollar
relief bill I signed into law last week
nearly three hundred and fifty billion
dollars in loans will soon be available
through lending partners to have small
businesses meet payroll and other
expenses for up to two months these
loans will be forgiven as long as
businesses keep paying their workers
absolutely accepted sort proprietors and
independent contractors applications
will be accepted starting this Friday
April 3rd so on Friday April 3rd that's
what it begins earlier today I spoke
with leading Internet and phone
providers who are doing a tremendous job
of keeping our internet and lines of
communication flowing under very
strongly increased strain the businesses
more than anybody seen before because
everyone's inside right we're all making
calls among the leaders I spoke to were
Hans vest Berg of Verizon Communications
Randall Stephenson of AT&T Mike Siebert
of t-mobile Thomas Rutledge of Charter
Communications Bryan Roberts of Comcast
john malone of liberty media dexter [ __ ]
of all t's boy Michael Combs of Sprint
and Araya Birkhoff of Lion tree also Pat
SR of Cox Communications and Jeffery
story of CenturyLink infomercial time
they're doing an incredible job if you
look at other continents if you look at
Europe they were on the ground that we
did and much different route we were
talking about that just a little while
ago and they're having tremendous
problems other countries are having
problems other continents are having
problems but with business at a level
that nobody's seen it before on the
internet it's
holding up incredibly well and they
expect that to continue no matter what
happened and no matter how much more it
gains which if it can gain more than it
already is I don't know because they're
setting records right let me also update
you on the distribution of urgency
needed resources and supplies and we
have a lot of numbers I'm going to let
Mike Pence speak to that in a little
while but we're giving massive amounts
of medical equipment and supplies to the
50 states yeah you see glitch there I
saw that or holding back quite a bit we
have almost 10,000 ventilators that we
have ready to go we have to hold them
back because the surge is coming and
it's coming pretty strong and we want to
be able to immediately move it into
place without going and taking it so
we're ready to go and we've also
distributed I just spoke with governor
of Michigan had a great conversation so
he is talking to her now we sent a large
number of ventilators to Michigan we're
sending them to Louisiana we sent
additional ventilators to New York
additional ventilators to New Jersey and
I will say in New York FEMA is supplying
250 ambulances and 500 EMTs to help
respond to the increasing caseload
that's a lot of ambulances in California
the Army Corps of Engineers is
developing eight facilities to expand
hospital capacity up to 50,000 beds
50,000 and had a great conversation last
night with Gavin Newsom he's doing he's
doing a really good job we were in
constant communications the USNS mercy
hospital ship is now operational it's in
Los Angeles and receiving patients and
in New York as you know the comfort
everybody watch that it's in place and
well
be very short while receiving large
numbers of patients over a thousand
rooms and twelve operating rooms
FEMA's also provided a hundred travel
trailers to assist with housing needs
and we're ordering hundreds more in
Michigan FEMA will soon deliver in
addition to the ventilators 250 bed
field hospital and Army Corps of
Engineers is evaluating locations to
build alternate care facilities so we're
doing a field hospital in Michigan of
250 beds that we may be doubling it up
soon depending on the need they're doing
a good job with with beds in Michigan
but they may need more than the 250 so
FEMA and the Army Corps of Engineers are
prepared to go there quickly
and get it done in Louisiana we're
delivering to field hospitals to provide
500 new hospital beds I've been talking
with the Governor John bel Edwards and
the Army Corps of Engineers has been
really doing incredible work
establishing 3,000 bed alternate care
site at the New Orleans Convention
Center which will be operational believe
it or not this week so we're doing the
3,000 bed alternate care site and we're
also doing a 500 bed new hospital and
that's in Louisiana which really got hit
it started off very late and it was
looking good and then all of a sudden it
just reared up came from nowhere in
addition to the supply resolvers dust
we're also giving hospitals the
flexibility to use new facilities
including surgical care centers to care
for hospital patients who are not
infected for example I know that many
expectant mothers are understandably
concerned about exposing their newborn
babies to the virus then they should be
with our action yesterday hospitals now
have the authority to create special
areas for mothers to deliver their
babies in a very safe and healthy
environment
totally separate over the past two
months the US State Department has
organized one of the largest and most
complex international evacuation
operations in American history Mike
Pompeo has been working round-the-clock
along with ambassador O'Brien since
January 29th we have successfully
repatriated over 25,000 Americans from
more than 50 countries where they were
literally stuck in some cases locked in
and I salute the incredible public
servants at the Department of State as
well as their counterparts at DHS and
HHS who have played such an important
role in doing this you probably read
about the young people in Peru and young
people in Brazil and they were
absolutely stuck and we got them out
right almost everybody is out now could
we get the death toll and model and
stuff their husbands I want every
American to be prepared for the hard
days that lie ahead we're gonna go
through a very tough two weeks and then
hopefully as the experts are predicting
is I think a lot of us are predicting
after having studied it's so hard you're
gonna start seeing some real light at
the end of the tunnel but this is going
to be a very painful very very painful
two weeks when you look and see at night
the kind of death that's been caused by
this invisible enemy it's it's
incredible I was watching last night
governor Murphy of New Jersey say 29
people died today meaning yesterday and
others talking about numbers far greater
but you get to know a state I know New
Jersey so well and you hit 29 people and
hundreds and other locations hundreds in
other states and this is going to be a
rough two-week period as a nation we
face a difficult few weeks as we
approach that that really important day
when we're gonna see things get better
all of a sudden and it won't be that
excited still be slow I really think and
I hope their strength will be tested and
our endurance will be tried but America
will answer with love and courage and
ironclad resolve this is the time for
all Americans to come together and do
our part now I appreciate a lot of the
media we've had a lot of really good
things said I think only good things can
be said when you look at the job that's
how God here we go I've just spoke with
Franklin Graham was an extraordinary
person wrong person to talk to and
Samaritan's Purse has been like so many
others just been amazing and so fast
they did it so fast he's been doing that
for a long time but I think people are
really seeing what they have done
Franklin Graham very special family as
we send plane loads of masks and gloves
and supplies to the communities battling
the plague and that's what it is is a
plague we also send our prayers we pray
for the doctors and the nurses for the
paramedics and the truck drivers and the
police officers and the sanitation
workers and above all the people
fighting for their lives in New York and
all across our land I watched as doctors
and nurses went into a certain Hospital
in Elmhurst this morning I know Elmhurst
Queens as I grew up right next to it I
know the hospital very well and staining
it all my life my young life and I will
tell you that to see the scenes of
[Music]
trailers out there
and what they're doing with those
trailers their freezers okay and nobody
could even believe it and I spoke to
some of my friends they can't believe
what they're seeing and I watched the
doctors and the nurses walking into that
hospital this morning it's like military
people going into battle going into war
the bravery is incredible
and I just have to take my hat I would
take my head if I were wearing I had I'd
ripped that hat off so fast and I would
say you people are just incredible hmm
they really are they're very brave
they're going in and they don't know you
have you have lots of things flying
around in the air you don't know what
you're touching is it safe really other
way with word you'll also see where you
have friends that go into the hospital
and you say how how is he doing two days
later and they say sir he's unconscious
or is in a coma so things are happening
that we've never seen before in this
country and with all of that being said
the countries come together like I've
never seen it before
and we will prevail we will win and
hopefully it will be in a relatively
short period of time with that I'd like
to ask dr. Burks to come up yes please
show you some of the ladders just the
data that has been I think brilliantly
put together and right after that I'm
gonna ask dr. found you to speak it's
the wind Mike bench is gonna give you
some of the recent events that have
taken place and some of the statistics
that we have that I think will be very
interesting to you thank you very much
experts Thank You mr. president um if I
could have the first slide please
so always and that's what this slide is
labeled is goals of community mitigation
really highlighting that this begins in
the middle and the end with community
this community and the community of the
American people that are going to have
to do the things for the next 30 days to
make a difference I think you know from
that large blue mountain that you can
see behind me and I just want to thank
the five or six international and and
domestic modelers from Harvard from
Columbia from North so understand the
framing now is it could have been 2.2
million look at how great Trump's doing
if we only get 200,000 deaths but
remember he said nobody was going to die
in 15 cases would become zero so this is
called reorienting go some call it
moving goal posts that's the curve from
that giant blue mountain down to that
more stippled area in their estimates
they had between 1.5 million and 2.2
million people in the united states are
coming to this virus without mitigation
again that estimate was down Studies and
showing us what social distancing would
do what people what would happen if
people stayed home what would happen if
people weren't careful every day to wash
their hands and worry about touching
their faces that what an extraordinary
thing this could be if every American
followed these and it takes us to that
stippled mountain that's much lower a
hill actually down to 100 to 200
thousand deaths which is still way too
much next slide please
simultaneously there was a modeler out
of the University of Washington that
modeled from cases up utilizing the
experience around the globe to really
understand how this information that we
have from Italy and Spain and South
Korea and China could really help us
give insight into the hospital needs the
ventilator needs and really the the
number of people who potentially could
succumb to this illness
it is this model that we are looking at
now that provides us the most detail of
the time course that is possible but
this model assumes full mitigation it's
informed every morning or every night by
the reality on the ground coming in from
New York New Jersey and around the
United States and is modeled and
informed every morning so that it is
adjusted so it is up-to-date every day
this is the model of the predicted
fatalities and mortality in the United
States and as the president said it's
very much focused on the next two weeks
and the stark reality of what this virus
will do as it moves through communities
next slide please
but this is a slide that gives us great
hope and understanding about what is
possible on the bottom of the slide
where you can barely see that blue line
at the very bottom that's the current
cases in California the cumulative cases
in California where they're doing
significant testing these are per capita
sign up is Connecticut the orange line
is New Jersey the blue line is New York
the yellow line is Washington we all
remember Washington State it was just a
month ago when they started to have the
issues in Washington State but they
brought together their communities and
their health providers and they put in
strong mitigation methods and testing
and you can see what the result in
Washington State and California is but
without the continuation for the next 30
days anything had changed right next
slide please
so I'm sure you're interested in seeing
all the states so on this slide is all
50 states and the District of Columbia
but I think it shows in stark reality
the difference between New York and New
Jersey and other states with similar
populations and urban areas our goal
over the next 30 days is to ensure the
state they have done
like kind of truncating and cropping of
these so that they're more readable
paying this lower level of new cases
with the hope that we don't have
significant outbreaks in other states
and other metro areas as the community
comes together to work together and
ensure that the healthcare providers
around the globe and in the United
States are strengthened by our resolve
to continue to mitigate community by
community this is done community by
community we all know people are in
their states and in their communities
and we're very dependent on each person
in the United States doing the same
thing following the presidential
guidelines to a tee I know it's a lot to
ask because you've done it for 15 days
so if you can show the next slide please
so this is what gives us a lot of hope
this is the case finding in Italy and
you can see that they're beginning to
turn the corner in new cases that that
this line here is an optimistic line and
anyway it's possible when we work
together as a community as a country to
change the course of this pandemic
together it is this graphic and the
graphic of many of the states that gives
us hope of what is possible with
continuing for another 30 days amidst
all that hope I must say that like we
warned about Detroit and Chicago we
start to see changes in Massachusetts
New Orleans continues to be a problem of
new cases although they're stabilizing
and I think it really shows the depth of
dedication of the American people to the
healthcare providers because they can
see the strain that this puts on every
nurse doctor respiratory therapist
pharmacist and laboratory technician
that's working together to stem this
tide I do wish we had briefings like
this every day looking at some different
you know element of the math the data
reporting instead of Trump bragging and
CEOs you know like I wish we had
something like this every day you can
see how
stressful it is on for each of them so I
know it's stressful to follow the
guidelines but it is more stressful and
more difficult to the soldiers on the
front line as we started and we will end
with it's communities that will do this
there's no magic bullet there's no magic
vaccine or therapy
it's just behaviors each of our behavior
is translating into something that
changes the course of this viral
pandemic over the next 30 days thank you
okay
now Tony thank you very much dr. Burks
mr. president mr. vice president
so what dr. Burks has really said very
simply is that there are really two
dynamic forces that are opposing each
other here as I mentioned several times
in our briefings the virus if left to
its own devices right we'll do that dark
curve that dr. Burks showed you the
other dynamic force is what we are doing
what we're trying to do and what we will
do in the form of mitigation now these
are very revealing bits of data because
you saw what happened in Italy where you
make the turn around the curve and you
go that doesn't happen all at once
it's a stepwise fashion and if I explain
the steps which I will you'll see why we
are really convinced that mitigation is
gonna be doing the trick for us because
we really understand that increase in
new cases at a certain rate when the
increase in new cases begin to level off
the secondary effect is less
hospitalizations the next effect is less
intensive care and the next effect is
less deaths look upon the deaths and the
intensive care and the hospitalization
always lagged behind that early
indication that there are less new cases
per day the way we saw in Italy and the
way we're likely seeing I don't want to
jump the gun on it we're seeing little
Inklings of this right now a new
yeah so what we're gonna see and that's
we gotta brace ourselves in the next
several days to a week or so we're gonna
continue to see things go up
we cannot be discouraged by that because
the mitigation is actually working and
we'll work the slide that dr. Berg
showed where you saw New York and New
Jersey and then the cluster of other
areas our goal which I believe we can
accomplish is to get the hotspot places
the New York's to New Jersey and help
them to get around that curve but as
importantly to prevent those clusters of
areas that have not yet gone to that
spike to prevent them from getting that
spike and the answer to that is
mitigation now the 15 days that we had
of mitigation clearly have had an effect
although it's tough to quantitate it
because of those two opposing forces but
the reason why we feel so strongly about
the necessity of the additional 30 days
is that now is the time whenever you're
having an effect not to take your foot
off the accelerator right and on the
brake but to just press it down on the
accelerator and that's what I hope and I
know that we can do over the next 30
days and as I said the other day and on
one of the one of the interviews we are
a very strong and resilient nation if
you look at our history we've been
through some terrible ordeals this is
tough people are suffering people are
dying it's inconvenient from a societal
standpoint from an economic standpoint
to go through this but this is gonna be
the answer to our problems so let's all
pull together and make sure as we look
forward to the next 30 days we do it
with all the intensity right force that
we can thank you
now we get back to nonsense Thank You
mr. president
dr. Burks and dr. Falchi I know I speak
on behalf of the president people all
across this country when I express our
great admiration and appreciation to
both of you for helping to steer our
nation through this challenging time the
American people have now seen what the
president saw when he made the decision
at the end of 15 days to slow the spread
to ask the American people to give us 30
more days to continue to put into
practice the president's coronavirus
guidelines for America and as you just
heard from the experts we have reason to
believe that it's working as dr. Fauci
just said there are difficult days ahead
our hearts and our prayers go out to the
families that have lost loved ones and
those as the president says reflected
who we know are struggling at this hour
and hospitals across the nation but to
each and every one of us do not be
discouraged because what you can do to
protect your health the health of your
family what you can do to ensure that
our our healthcare providers have the
resources and our hospitals have the
capacity to meet this moment is put into
practice the presidents of coronavirus
guidelines for America it really is what
every American can do 30 days to slow
the spread 30 days to make a difference
in the lives of the American people
American families and the life of our
nation allow me to give you a few brief
updates before the president takes
questions first and foremost we continue
to work very closely with governor's
around the nation president I spoke to
all the governors all the states and
territories yesterday and since we were
last together the President and I are
spoken directly and to several
governor's around the country including
Illinois Louisiana Michigan New
and other states at the present moment
the president has declared 29 major
disaster declarations and authorized at
10 different states to use full federal
funding so-called title 32 funding to
pay for their National Guard and as of
this afternoon FEMA reports some 17,000
National Guard have been activated in
states around the country to provide
support for coronavirus response on the
subject of testing we have now completed
more than 1.1 million tests around the
country we're working very closely with
governor's around America to to assist
them in drive-through and community
testing centers I spoke with governor JB
Pritzker of Illinois today about a
testing center that they've established
in cooperation with the US Public Health
Service we remind every governor and
every laboratory and hospital in the
country it's imperative that you
continue to report daily to the CDC the
results of those tests to give us the
visibility on the data to best inform
resource decisions also we we reiterated
today to governor's in person and and
also through correspondence to every
governor the importance of using their
National Guard if need be to move
medical supplies FEMA is very busy as
you'll hear in a moment delivering
literally millions of supplies to states
around the country but we're urging
every governor to make sure to work with
their state emergency management team
and maybe use the National Guard to move
those supplies from warehouses to
hospitals right at the present moment as
the president said we've distributed
more than 11.6 million in 95 masks more
than 80-100 ventilators around the
nation
millions of face shields surgical masks
and gloves we initiate an air bridge
that the president announced yesterday
flights have arrived in New York one
arrived in Illinois yesterday and a
flight will arrive in
in the next 24 hours FEMA is literally
working and contracting around the world
with now more than 51 flights that will
be bringing vital medical supplies on
the subject of ventilators FEMA is
currently delivering 400 ventilators to
Michigan 300 in New Jersey 150 to
Louisiana 50 ventilators to Connecticut
and in the last week and in the week
ahead more than 450 ventilators to
Illinois this is in addition to more
than 4,400 ventilators at the President
and FEMA directed to the state of New
York
we just want people that are working on
the front lines that the president just
spoke about dr. Burks and dr. found she
spoke about we want you to know help is
on the way and at the president's
direction we're gonna leave no stone
unturned anywhere in America or anywhere
in the world to make sure that you have
the resources and the equipment to do
your job so again I want to just say
thank you America thank you for stepping
up thank you for putting into practice
the 15 days to slow the spread and thank
you for the response that tens of
millions have already had for the 30
days to slow the spread we encourage
each one of you as we have governor's
around the country to spread the word
about the guidelines listen to your
state and local authorities in areas
that are more greatly impacted yes we
continue to urge people in the areas of
New York New Jersey and Connecticut to
refrain from travel around the country
people who've traveled from that area
check your temperature and self
quarantine for 14 days you can see from
that chart the unique challenges people
in the Greater New York City area are
facing with the coronavirus and we want
to do all that we can to protect your
health focus resources and the community
and prevent unnecessary spread lastly as
the president highlighted yesterday
businesses around America are stepping
up as never before
tomorrow I'll travel with secretary
sonny Perdue to Gordonsville Virginia to
the Walmart distribution center just so
the American people can see firsthand
how the foods that a good idea what
about just roll to materials and through
air
all over America and we thank again the
grocery store operators around America
and everybody that's working out on the
highways and byways every day to keep
that food supply rolling and rolling
strong to the American people though we
we just want to assure you that we're
going to continue to work our hearts out
work our hearts out to make sure our
healthcare providers have everything
they need that anyone struggling with
coronavirus has a support and health
care their need I'm absolutely confident
seeing the way our governors are
responding seeing this team the
president has assembled in the White
House coronavirus task force confident
of the prayers of the American people
that will get through this but it will
take all of us doing our part and we'll
get through it together thanks Mike
just to be clear what is the projected
death toll should people be reasonably
good at following these mitigation
measures well they're reasonably good I
guess we could say that I'd like to have
it be doctor taught you or Deb come up
and say but I have he doesn't want to be
on camera saying that 82 to 40 K so of
course this is a projection and it's a
projection based on using very much
what's happened in Italy and then
looking at all the models and so as you
saw on that slide that was our real
number about a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand and we think that that
is the range we really believe in hope
every day that we can do a lot better
than that because that's not assuming a
hundred percent of every American does
everything that they're supposed to be
doing but I think that's possible the
next two weeks is you said the next two
weeks are gonna be very painful as the
bulk of it's gonna happen over the next
you have an upslope
so as mortality the fatalities to this
disease will increase and then it will
come back down and it will come back
down slower than the rate at which it
went up yeah and so that's
is really the issue how how much we can
push the mortality down yeah so our hope
is to get that down as for as far as we
possibly can the modeling that dr. Berg
showed predicts that number that you saw
we don't accept that number that that's
what it's gonna be we're gonna be doing
everything we can to get it even
significantly below that so you know I
don't want it to be a mixed message this
is the thing that we need to anticipate
but that doesn't mean that that's what
we're gonna accept we want to do much
much better than that it goes much
further in time so we would have death
and cases for much longer I mean we do
expect slide number two so that's a
generic I'm sorry we can go back to the
slides and put a fly - that's okay so
what I showed you was a generic picture
of what happens in an epidemic when you
mitigate so no mitigation mitigate this
is based on the experience around the
globe with this particular virus right
and so it does have a tail but the peak
you can see by this projection and this
is the eye hme data the peak is over the
next two weeks and that site and this is
tracking mortality so the number of
fatalities from this virus and so that's
the part that we think we can still
blunt through the superb medical care
that every client is receiving but also
even more stringent people following the
guidelines I can't see the small
characters but are we seeing death until
June I can't really
so we would still see problems and
deaths in June we was getting back to
what I said about the stepwise thing
deaths always lag so you will be seeing
deaths at a time when as an epidemic
we're doing really really well because
the deaths will lag we're the likelihood
that there will be a hundred thousand
Americans who die from this virus yeah
the answer is yes we need as sobering a
number as that is we should be prepared
for it is it going to be that much I
hope not and I think the more we push on
the mitigation the less likelihood it
would be that number but as being
realistic
we need to prepare ourselves that that
is a possibility that yes was a short
period of time for that to happen but
Kenda country handle that in such a
short period of time within a couple of
months you know in a month you know it
will be difficult I mean no one is
denying the fact that we are going
through a very very difficult time right
now I mean we're seeing what's happening
in New York that is really really tough
and if you extrapolate that to the
nation that will be really tough but
that's what it is Jim and we're gonna
have to be prepared for that I think
real tired of that model that was from I
hme that's based and heavily laden by
the data that has come in from New York
and New Jersey and Connecticut so you
know that can skew to a higher peak and
more significant mortality if all of the
other states are able and I all the
other metro areas are able to hold that
case number down then it's a very
different picture but you have to
predict on the data you have which is
heavily skewed to New York and New
Jersey
getting back to that that's really an
important slide that dr. Berg showed the
cluster which has happened to the
audience that are not New York and not
New Jersey if we can suppress that from
any kind of a spike the numbers could be
significantly lower than what we're
talking about they're not following
these guys plea at the end of my remarks
Jim that now is the time to put your
foot on the accelerator because that was
that double audio to stop those piece
this mic might have died I think we're
just getting this one right here would
you tell cities that aren't doing what
you know New York New Jersey Washington
you know the cities that have been
taking charge and all of this would you
urge some of the cities that haven't
been doing this mr. president to get
with the program and I wouldn't if you
see
having so much harder time that other of
the city's certain cities and states
actually they were early they were very
very firm remember California in
Washington state we're down here and
they had some in the early case what
we're seeing places in Florida not doing
what in New York in New Jersey I've been
doing what Washington state has been
that we have very well Florida is gonna
be in trouble the question to you and
then to dr. Falchi as well we you told
us yesterday that your accomplishment of
the US at least is accomplishing a
hundred thousand tests per day we're
still hearing
difficult stories from the front lives
of the first responders to you this
audio so appropriately a little while
ago that they can't test all of the
people that they need to test do you
have any kind of projection as to when
everyone who needs a test will be able
to receive yeah I can only say that
we're doing more than anybody in the
world by far we are testing highly
accurate tests is a test that work as
you know many tests are being sent to
countries broken well we're doing
everyday we get and the word is
exponential we are getting more and more
and more and now we have the new test
that you saw yesterday that's gonna be
rolled out I think tomorrow or the next
day and that's gonna take only a few
minutes literally a few minutes to see
the result and it's a highly accurate
result I mean the tests were given out
not by us by other countries where there
was a 50/50 chance that it was wrong
what kind of a test is that these are
highly accurate tests but the new tests
that are coming out are very quick and
they were just developed Abbott Labs did
the one yesterday so we're doing more
than anybody in the world by far and
they're very accurate tests and we're
getting a lot of information for its
baddest
the test president unveiled yesterday
the Abbott Laboratories test which is a
15 minute test our team is working very
closely with ambrosia raw and FEMA to
make sure that those are distributed
around around the country earlier this
week Abbott Laboratories actually going
to be producing 50,000 tests a day and
distributing those around America
there's already the machines in some
18,000 different locations around the
country and they've told us they have
several thousand on the Shelf now and
what we're doing is trying to identify
the areas where we may yet have pockets
or as dr. Burks often says we're where
we want to do more immediate testing so
that we can do what's called
surveillance testing to identify where
where there may be corona virus cases
where there's been very little incident
but if I could just amplify one other
point and that is that when you look at
this chart go back 15 days and the
reality is that and this is me speaking
as a layperson
but as I've listened to our experts in
New York and the Greater New York City
area you have unique challenges it's a
it's a city that we we really believe
may have had exposure to the corona
virus much earlier on then and we could
have known and had its own challenges in
New York Connecticut New Jersey are
leaning into this effort but when when
we look at this chart for all the other
states including Washington state in
California it really does give evidence
that at least it begins to give evidence
that the 15 days to slow the spread is
working and that in fact the American
people are putting these things into
practice in states across the country
including in New York and New Jersey
even though they've they faced a greater
magnitude of cases but for certain
circumstances that are related to
international travel in those
communities guys I know the audio is
messed up the these mics aren't turning
on it's just this weird crowd mic they
have it's a mess and they can see that
in the last 15 days
the presidents coronavirus guidelines
were working and that's precisely why
President Trump is asking every American
to continue to put these guidelines into
practice for 30 more days so right now
we're at about four thousand deaths here
the United States you suggesting they
spiked of more than ninety thousand
deaths over the next few weeks do you
have a demographic breakdown of the
areas that are most in Westham where
most of those deaths we know all that
well right now and I think if you ask
Chris Murray he would say he's using the
information coming out of New York and
New Jersey and applying that to
potentially other states having the same
outcomes I just want to say again this
yellow line is now in line and this is
all corrected for a hundred thousand
residents so this is normalized so we
can compare apples to apples per capita
so they've been able to for a long time
of measuring cases not have a spike so
it's possible and we're watching very
closely to make sure it doesn't have a
spite but that's what the people in
Washington state are doing this is what
every community so it Washington state
early about two weeks before New York or
New Jersey California a week before New
York or New Jersey really talked to
their communities and decided to
mitigate before they started seeing this
number of cases and now we know that
that makes a big difference
early as dr. Falchi said if you wait
till you see it it's too late you have a
demographic breakdown doctor burse of
where these deaths may occur so there's
a Democrat deaf demographic breakdown
that we've discussed before related to
mortality and it's a we're gonna try
another stream or see if the audios
better and it's as we're seeing in New
York exactly what we saw in Italy
very low mortality not to say that you
need to be the same issue 30 or young
people under 40 aren't getting ill they
are but most of them are recovering so
the profile looks identical to ill ill
Italy with increasing mortality with age
and pre-existing medical conditions and
so that is holding in the same way but
what we're hoping is that through the
work of communities and again it comes
down to communities this is not this is
communities deciding that this is
important to them to not have the
experience of New York and New Jersey
and I think you know we are worried
about groups all around the globe I mean
I don't know if you heard the rumor
there's 8,000 ventilators in the back we
don't if you translate that to United
States that would be like the United
States having less than 40,000
ventilators we have five times that
amount go care position but we don't
want to have to test that system we want
this to be a much smaller epidemic with
much smaller mortality follow-up
question real quick before we move on so
so the testing numbers I understand a
million tests done it's a big increase
but we were told there would be 27
million tests available by the end of
the month
so you outlined we're in the supply
chain we're in the logistics chain are
those other 26 you know where are the
other 26 million tests right I think
this is just for purposes of
clarifications there's a difference
between sending a test that can be
administered to a test being done and
because a month ago or more the
president brought together the top
commercial labs in America and said we
need you to partner with us to to create
a brand new system that would rapidly
process tests
we're now at 1.1 million tests and we
believe it's a fair estimate that we're
testing about a hundred thousand
Americans a day that'll continue to grow
it'll continue to accelerate but I think
the misunderstanding early on was there
were many tests being distributed many
test kits being sent but under the old
system as the presidents described it
the antiquated system those were being
processed in in state labs or at CDC or
in private labs on a very slow
methodical a system that could only
produce maybe 30 to 50 tests a day but
this new partnership that we have with
commercial laboratories allows the
progress we're making
but the breakthrough with Abbott
Laboratories now moves to point-of-care
which means you're going to have devices
and tests that people will literally be
able to take at their doctor's office at
a hospital at a clinic at a nursing home
and have the results in 15 minutes so
there's a twenty six million tests we
were talking about were those tests
under the old and
system now so are we still even using
those those 27 million tests or have we
just completely moved on to the pointers
yes even today which is I have to say
coming out of laboratories and developed
tests and worked on vaccines and I'm
gone to the field to actually combat
epidemics it is disappointing to me
right now that we have about 500,000
capacity of Abid tests that are not
being utilized so they are out there in
the states they're not being run and not
utilized so now we have to figure out
how do we create awareness because
sometimes when you put an early platform
out like our first platform out so you
get that out people get dependent on
that and then don't see that there's
availability of other tests so right now
there's over a half a million tests
sitting capacity that are not being
utilized so we're trying to figure out
how do we inform states about where
these all are how do we work through
every laboratory where and how do we
raise awareness so people know that
there's point of care
there's thermo Fisher there's Abbott
testing and there's Roche and if you add
those together that's millions of tests
a week or they're not even being used so
that's what's really so that's what
we're working on because when people get
used to a single platform they keep
sending it back to that lab so it's
getting in a queue to wait to get on a
Roche machine rather being moved to this
other lab that may have avek capacity
because they're all in different
laboratories and so I think well
actually Admiral girar is figuring it
out to really create some kind of visual
so that every governor and every health
commissioner can see all of their
capacity in their countries I mean in
their states county by county so that
they know where the tests are so we
pushed a lot of tests out but they're
not all being utilized
they use them they don't send it back I
mean dr. Burks explained it very very
well I just want to get back John to
your question it's a logical question
when you look at the number you want to
know what the demography is gonna be
this is a number that we need to
anticipate but we don't necessarily have
to accept that as being inevitable and
that's getting back to what I'm saying
about we can influence this to a varying
degrees and if we influence it to the
maximum we don't have to accept that
that's something we need to anticipate
but I want to do not I all of us want to
do much much better than that in that
what are the models suggest he's on the
low end if you have full mitigation if
you guys are confused I understand why
it's a lot of people well you didn't ask
the other question what would have
happened because this is the question
that I've been asked of fair this is
Trump's new propaganda a long time and
if I did nothing it could have been 2.2
is what would have happened if we did
nothing because there was a group that
said let's just write it out let's write
it out what would have happened and that
number comes in at 1.5 to 1.6 million
people up to 2.2 and even beyond so that
it's a worthless comparison because
Trump's actually saying I could have
done nothing at all which would not be
acceptable of course I think that would
have been possible because you would
have had people dying all over the place
this would not have been a normal life
how many people have even seen anybody
die you would have seen people dying on
airplanes you would have been seeing
people dying in hotel lobbies you would
have where people would have been dying
on the airplanes a practical standpoint
that couldn't have been carried out too
far by but but if you if you did nothing
on the higher side the number would be
2.2 and maybe even more and on the lower
side 1.6 million people
100,000 is the number with a full
mitigation of how do you push it so John
it's an obvious very good question if
this is full mitigating mitigation and
it's a hundred thousand why am i
standing there saying I want to make it
better because that's what the model
tells you what's gonna do what we do is
that every time we get more data you
feed it back in and relook at the model
is the model really telling you what's
actually going on and again I know my
modeling colleagues are gonna not be
happy with me but models are as good as
the assumptions you put into them and as
we get more data then you put it in and
that might change so even though it says
according to the model which is a good
model that we're dealing with this is
full mitigation as we get more data as
the week's go by later that could be
modified why does the model now the top
line on the lowball estimate why does
that not talk about it I think it's a
240,000 not two hundred thousand is that
it change is that cuz the states have
been doing enough you know it just has
to do with if you had more New York's
and New Jersey's you know it's acog Oh
Detroit LA Dallas Houston you know all
of our major cities modeled like New
York that's what gets us into trouble
but I am reassured by looking at the
Seattle line by looking at the LA line
by looking at what Cal Austin has been
able to do that that is not something
that I don't believe that's gonna happen
that is the outside case of having 1015
metros like New York and the New Jersey
metro area New York had community spread
pretty early undetected so don't many of
those other states if not more
even less information aren't they likely
to see the same let's fight
well California and Washington state
reacted very early to this I
yes Washington State had some of the
earliest infections they have kept it
low and steady and for now a month has
been tracking it with a small increase
in the number of cases but not this
logarithmic form of the virus and so
that's the that's the piece that we're
trying to prevent that's the piece that
we're trying to prevent in New Orleans
in Detroit in Chicago and in Boston
right now and and trying to make sure
that each of those cities work more like
California than the New York metro I
think we are here in Boston I just want
to get your thoughts on face masks we
asked you about this yesterday and you
signaled you were thinking about it I
think I could say this because I spoke
to dr. Burks before and to dr.
fair-cheeked for whatever reason New
York got off to a very late start and we
see what happens when you get off to a
late start New Jersey get off too and I
think both governors are doing an
excellent job but they got off to a very
late start when you look at Washington
State if you remember that all started
in a very confined nursing home and you
had 20 some-odd people I believe dying
in one home that doesn't mean it escaped
that home and so they have a very
different statistic than other states
but I mean I remember it very vividly
spaceman in Washington state where you
had many people dying every day people
were dying in the one exact location so
they were able to keep that relatively
speaking in to that location
[Music]
were you surprised when you saw these
projections the numbers are sobering
they're very sobering you know when you
see a hundred thousand people that said
and that's at a minimum number now what
we're looking at and as many people as
we're talking about whatever we can do
under that number and substantially
under that number we've done that
through really great mitigation we've
done that through a lot of very
dedicated American people that you know
a hundred thousand is is according to
modeling a very low number in fact that
when I first saw the number and I asked
this a while ago they said it's unlikely
you'll be able to attain that I think
we're doing better than now I think we
have to see but I think we're doing
better than that because as John said
that would be it doesn't explain you
know he doesn't understand the rapid
growth of a virus but a period of time
but think of what would have happened if
we didn't do anything I mean I was just
an anon friends business people people
with great actually common sense they
said what are we right at a lot of
people have said a lot of people have
thought about it write it out don't do
anything just right there and think of
it as the flu but it's not the food it's
vicious when you send a friend to the
hospital and you call up to find out how
is he doing it happened to me yep coma
where goes to the hospital he says
goodbye sort of a tough guy a little
older a little heavier then he'd like to
be frankly and you go up the next day
how's he doing and he's in a coma this
is not the flu so we would have seen
things head was nothing he said it was
well I think we're asking that question
I think right I was asking it also I
mean a lot of people were saying well
let's just write it out this is not to
be written out because then you would
have been looking at potentially 2.2
million people are more 2.2 million
Rypple in a relatively short period of
time if you remember remember before it
was I don't have to do anything because
there's no risk now it's a hundred
thousand wouldn't be bad because if I
did nothing it would be 2.2 million so
he's actually really great but they were
looking at that in the UK remember they
were very much
and all of a sudden they went hard the
other way because they started seeing
things that weren't good so they they
were they were seeing things you know
they put themselves in a little bit of a
problem now Boris tested positive and I
hear he's hope he's gonna be fine
basically Trump might save two million
people is the way he's couching it and
they have a name for it but we won't
even call we won't even go by the name
but it would have been it would have
been very catastrophic I think if that
would have happened but that was
something that everybody was talking
about safe like just don't do anything
don't do anything forget about
everything just write it up they use the
expression write it out we would have
had at a minimum 1.5 1.6 but you would
have had perhaps more than 2.2 million
people dying in a very short period of
time and that would have been a number
that the likes of which we've never seen
so now when we look at our package that
we just approved for two trillion
dollars all of a sudden it seems very
reasonable right when you're talking
about two million lives all of a sudden
it seems very reasonable I must say a
lot of people that have been seeing the
more advanced numbers because these are
much more advanced numbers talking about
when you first started we didn't know
and this was a different kind of a virus
and nobody knew that much about it even
the experts you don't really know where
it's going we've been studying what goes
on in Italy and they see what goes on in
Spain and you see France is having a
very hard time and other countries
having a very very hard time but once
they see what's going on they start
making projections so I hope they're
going to be very high projections but
based on everything else that would be
the number let's see if we can do much
better than that
okay well I understand there's an issue
with supply actually if there was you
know you can use a scarf scarf is
everybody a lot of people have scarfs
and you can use this girl would be very
good and my my feeling is if people want
to do it there's certainly no harm to it
I would say do it but use a scarf if you
want you know rather than going out and
getting a mask or whatever we're making
millions and millions of masks well boy
want them to go to the hospitals I mean
one of the things that dr. Falchi told
me he's not wrong that a scarf in a mask
is the same thing just the masks lattice
is way smaller the scarfs lattice is
better than zero but it's obviously to
it and use something else over your face
it doesn't have to be a mask but it's
not a bad idea at least for a period of
time I mean eventually you're not gonna
want to do that you're not gonna have to
do that this is going to be gone it'll
be done hopefully gone for a long time
mitigation steps on your 30 day plan is
that enough for you have you been well
we're gonna find out we hope it's enough
we hope it's enough we hope we're at a
level where we could say let's go
because our country wants to get back to
work we really want to get back
everybody wants to get back to work
now I could ask the doctors to answer
that question but we discussed that all
the time what do you think sure I think
we've been very harsh I mean you look at
the streets I looked at Fifth Avenue
today on camera and I didn't see anybody
walking on the street and I'm used to
watching that Street you can't even see
you can't see the asphalt you can't see
the concrete and you look at this nobody
there was one car it looked like it
might have been a taxicab and it was in
a tie day morning than normally there'd
be a lot of people I mean you know I
think I think there mitigation has been
very strong please mr. president
you confirm your plans to defer tariff
payments for 90 days and secondly ami I
didn't I didn't do anything about tariff
favorites I don't know who's talking
about tariff payments they keep talking
about tariff payments and we haven't
done that China's paying us we made a
deal with China and well we David there
is 25% on two hundred and fifty billion
dollars our company and I spoke with
President Xi the other day and he didn't
mention that we didn't mention that we
had a great conversation by the way a
really productive conversation having to
do with many things most of it was on
the virus but you know we're not talking
to who you were who you were if I can
just clear a lot of Wall Street drum
there's reporting by Wall Street Journal
uber that there's a plan of motion -
well it might be but I'm gonna have to
approve the plan I will tell you I
approve everything and they haven't
presented it to me right so therefore
it's false reporting so therefore don't
do the story if we've also false to say
that China pays the tariffs I'd be glad
to let you know there's nothing wrong
with doing it but well let you know yeah
please look a couple of back there look
it thank you John thank you thanks sir
politics I wanted to ask you about
individual states issuing stay at home
or what do you think for instance in
Florida Rhonda Sanchez has resisted
urges to issue one of those but he said
moments ago that if you and the rest of
the task force recommended one that
would weigh on him heavily what sort of
doom stances need to be in place for you
to make that call and say this is
something she's saying it right in kind
of a state also great governor knows
exactly what he's doing has a very
strong view on it and we have spoken to
Ron Mike you want to just tell them a
little bit about that Lord is exploding
well let me echo our appreciation for
governor DeSantis leadership in Florida
he's been taking decisive steps from
early on live and working closely with
our team at the federal level but let me
be very clear on this the recommendation
of our health experts was to take the 15
days to slow the spread
and have the president extend that to 30
days for every American right now that
being said we recognize that that when
you're dealing with a health crisis in
the country it is it is locally executed
by health care workers but it's state
managed and so we continue to flow
information to state governors we
continue using healthy sounds that do it
got data that they're analyzing and
consult with them shut it down but at
the president's Direction the White
House coronavirus task force will
continue to take the posture that we
will defer to state and local health
authorities on any measures that they
deem appropriate
but for the next 30 days this is what we
believe every American in every state
should be doing at a minimum to tell us
to do now it's obviously wrong I mean
people look at Miami it's obvious make a
decision that we think is so far out
that it's wrong we will stop that but in
the case of governor to scientists you
know there's two thoughts to it and two
very good thoughts to it and he's been
doing a great job in every respect so
we'll see what happens but we only would
exercise somebody was very obvious big
economic concern for
people's in the state of oil prices
right now yeah
so I'm wondering if you raised that with
President Putin if you were able to in
any other coral it was probably about
that - the oil prices it was probably
about oil and Russia and Saudi Arabia
going at it and they're really going at
it and by going at it to the extent that
they are the oil has dropped to a point
where I look it's the greatest tax cut
we've ever given the cheap gas can't
drive anywhere cheap flights can't fly
anywhere for a gallon of gasoline
it's incredible on a lot of ways gonna
help the airlines but at the same time
it's hurtful - one of our biggest
industries that's the oil industry it's
really it's not even feasible what's
going on so I spoke to President Putin
about that I also spoke to the crown
prince about that Saudi Arabia know I
think yeah they're gonna get together
and we're all gonna get together and
we're gonna see what we can do because
you don't want to lose an industry
you're gonna lose an industry over it in
thousands and thousands of jobs we have
I don't know if you know there's oil all
over the oceans right now the boats are
all filled they ship so they're renting
ships ships that were dying that weren't
doing well and now like their that's
where they're storing oil and they're
sent out to sea and they sit there for
long periods of time there's so much oil
in some cases it's it's probably less
valuable than water in some parts of the
world water is much more valuable so if
we've never seen anything like it
right but the two countries are
beautiful countries discussing it and I
I am joining at the appropriate time if
need be we had a great talk with
President Putin we had a great talk with
the crown prince we also discussed more
so with President Putin in this case the
virus because Russia is being hit pretty
hard and we discussed many things trade
we discussed a lot of things with both
but in the case of both we very much
discussed the oil in the oil prices I
mean you look it's $22 but it's really
much cheaper than that if you want to
negotiate nobody's seen that that's like
from the 1950s
it really is you know to think that it
was 50 60 70 80 and now it's 22 but you
know if you put a good bit in at nine I
think you could probably get what you
wanted right right John Cleese I take
three batteries included earlier today
that now would be a good time to start
looking for if there is a light at the
end of the towel and work on an
infrastructure bill again you suggest
that it should be two trillion dollars
which is twice where the last one was or
the proposal released are you
anticipating that like after the
economic crisis of 2008 2009 America
will need to have so-called shovel ready
jobs ready to go to get people back to
work well the problem with that one is
they had maybe shovel ready jobs and
maybe not but they never used it for the
purpose of infrastructure so far nobody
has been able to find any money that was
spent on infrastructure I want to use it
for infrastructure and wonderful
wondering why he goes to John Roberts
all the time he's with Fox News the
states is paying almost zero interest
rate the federal reserve lowered the
rate the Fed rate and that and a
combination of the fact that everybody
wants to be in the United States you
know we have the $1 that's very strong
and I know that sounds good but it does
make it hard to manufacture and sell
outside because other currencies are
falling in our currency is very strong
it's too strong should be good portion
Utley it's through the roof so we have a
strong dollar people want to invest in
the United States especially nowadays
where they're looking at safety they
have all of the problems plus the virus
at 151 countries they all want to come
into the United States and so we have a
zero interest rate essentially and I
said wouldn't this be a great time to
borrow money at zero interest rate and
really build our infrastructure like we
can do it so the plan was the
Republicans had a plan of about 750 I
would say they were we're at 75 what you
had the Democrats were a little less
than a trillion dollars the Republicans
were a little bit less than that and I'm
suggesting two trillion dollars we redo
our roads our highways our bridges we
fix up our tunnels which are many of
them in bad shape
like coming into New York as you know
really bad shape and we really do a job
on our infrastructure and that doesn't
mean we're gonna do the green new deal
because I won't do it I won't approve it
when I do the green new deal and never
never no spend you know 40% of the money
on things that people just have fun with
the money at 0% interest so our interest
payments would be almost zero and we can
borrow long-term he doesn't get what to
be in the United States they want to be
invested in the United States go ahead
Jim
I want to get back to the virus you were
saying at the beginning of the press
conference that you're looking at
holding back 10,000 ventilators is that
because you need to pick and choose
where these ventilators are going to
have to go because of the nature of the
pandemic why she's bringing it all so I
just want to ask dr. factory and dr.
Burks if it's possible after you
finished is that part of the reason why
you're projecting a hundred thousand to
two hundred thousand deaths that they're
going to be some people who aren't going
to be able to get ventilators or people
actually gives the opposite result Tim
McCaw holding back we have almost 10,000
and we're holding because we're gonna
need them over the next couple of weeks
as this surge goes on you see the chair
we haven't hit the top yet and we have
to be able to move them immediately and
we can't take them because it's gonna be
very hard to do that we can't take them
to places that aren't needing them plus
we have requests for ventilators in
hospitals and in states and cities that
don't need them in our opinion they
don't need them they won't need them at
the top so we're holding it back for
flexibility we actually just took 600
and we sent them to different locations
today but we have close to 10,000 and
we'll be able to get them and we're all
set to March we have the National
Guard's and we have FEMA and we're all
set to move them to the places so as for
your second question what we're gonna do
is save lives because of it because
otherwise we would not be able to get to
the events and we don't know what the
hottest spot is and later shortage right
now in some areas we might but we've
done a great job with ventilators and
we're having a maid but if there is a
shortage in some places and you're
sitting on 10k don't they need it now
arrive in the next week but we've also
grabbed a lot of them
some hospitals had more than they were
saying or at least more than we knew
about which is a good thing not a bad
thing but we want to be able to have I
guess the word would be flexibility so
that if the surge turns out to be much
stronger in Louisiana which it could
that we can immediately bring a thousand
or two thousand to Louisiana otherwise
we wouldn't be able to get him we
wouldn't be able to say listen
Governor Cuomo in New York we want to
take ventilators are away from New York
and they'll say well we can't do that
it would be a disaster so we have great
flexibility now when the surge occurs if
it occurs fairly evenly we'll be able to
distribute them very quickly before they
need them but we want to have we have a
reserve right now it's like having oil
reserves it's now a valuable frankly but
we have a reserve right now and we'll be
able and we also have a great team of
people ready to deliver they can move
them fast so when we see it going up in
a certain state and Louisiana could be
one and Michigan could be another with
Detroit because Detroit is that some of
these don't even work by the way these
been two leaders Lloyd came out of
nowhere and that's what happens with
this it comes out of nowhere so we are
ready Jim depending on what happens and
we have a stockpile and that's why it's
called a stockpile now a lot of the
ventilators and a lot of the other
equipment we're sending it to the stock
file we had it sent directly to a
hospital to a location to a place so we
didn't have the cumbersome nature of
having it come in unboxed put it and
then deliver it we have it brought which
they've never done before they don't do
that generally speaking they don't do
that but we've had I think Mike we've
had tremendous success at doing that
that's for other items including
ventilators where it's brought to the
site that needs it but we have a good
supply of ventilators and we're ready to
go we're all ready we have trucks ready
we have everything ready because as
we're saying John this could be a hell
of a bad two weeks this is go back and
talk to John good I feel bad too and
maybe even three weeks this is going to
be three weeks like we haven't seen
before
should the hospital
for that well I think the hospitals
they're facing what looks like a medical
wars yeah they are going to be facing
the war so and that's what it is Trump
elected some of them it's funny Acosta
is used raising the war zone language
again but Trump relishes that language
he wants to be seen as a guy fighting a
war here I've never seen I mean I look I
just think it's so cuz that's a hospital
that's near where I grew up and it's it
is a war zone in a true sense you have
places on the ventilator so we've been
hearing from governor's who say they are
fighting amongst themselves essentially
bidding amongst themselves you sure
you're doing that's like if that happens
they should be calling us they are we
have ventilators but we've distributed
thousands of ventilators but they
shouldn't be doing that
and if they need them that badly we know
we have pretty good ideas of where
they're going to need them some people
frankly think they need him and they
don't need him right Trump no mention
names but there are some people that
want them and it's really not the right
thing then you have some people that I
guess automatically hoard a little bit
they want to have more than they think
they need but you know a ventilator is a
very precious piece of equipment right
now yeah it's hard to make it takes a
long time to make it it's complex some
of them are like the dashboard of an
airplane I mean they're very complicated
and very expensive machines and some are
much simpler here we go again but we're
ready to go depending on what happens
but we have some hospitals in some
states that think they need ventilators
and we don't think they do now if they
do need them we will have them there
before they need them we'll be able to
move very quickly on these trials
nothing that I've heard I mean that's
the first question I make every morning
I'll tell you I call up you know we have
1,100 1,100 in New York right now and we
have other locations where there where
patients people are taking them now the
good news is it's only three days and
you know it's like a seven or eight day
treatment the good news is we haven't
heard anything bad in other words
there's no catastrophic events but we
haven't it's a little bit too soon to
talk
it would be a total GameChanger John if
that happened if that happened it would
be a game-changer and we include that in
that and I think in all cases the z-pak
you know the z-pak is right so we're
gonna see what happens with the hydroxy
some show promise could a doctor talk
about I think maybe the doctor might
want to speak about the vaccines yes a
lot of know another guy Johnson &
Johnson is advanced very advanced we'll
see what happens
our one thing with the vaccine issue it
doesn't help this group because this
group it's you know you need to test a
vaccine the one thing with the drug you
just mentioned right is that that's been
out it's a malaria drug and also an
arthritis drug so it's been out there
for a long time very powerful drug but
it's been out there for a long time so
it's tested in the sense that you know
it doesn't kill you but you may want to
discuss the vaccines for a second I
would like to hear him talk about rim
desafio another president but just for a
second before the vaccine an answer to
your question see there are a number of
candidates the the drugs that are now
being looked at in various ways either
compassionate use clinical trials are
generally drugs that already exist for
other things there's a whole menu of
drugs and interventions that are now
going into clinical trials that are not
approved for anything yet I mean for
example things like immune serum
convalescent plasma or hyper
immunoglobulin or monoclonal antibodies
a variety of other things right now
there's a lot of activity going on
behind the scenes in the design of the
kinds of clinical trials that will give
us an answer because you need an answer
because if it doesn't work you want to
get it off the table you'll go to the
next one so there are a lot of things
vaks normally take there's no weeks
months you know it takes at least months
at least months at least so I mean
that's the reason why you're seeing a
lot of activity with drugs that already
exist for other purposes because they're
already there
yeah but the drugs that you want to show
in a good randomized clinical trial had
very best they're gonna take months just
one word in the vaccine
you know exactly like we said we hope
that as we get into the summer if in
fact there are cases out there when
you're in a phase 2 or phase 3 trial or
two to be as we call it that we might
get an early efficacy signal and an
efficacy signal means that even though
you haven't definitively proven that a
vaccine works you get enough information
that if it were an emergency you might
be able to have an emergent it's
actually a huge deal that foul she's
even mentioning that hydroxychloroquine
and as it remain which is you know you
take it with it maybe if you want if you
want your infection I think some medical
workers are doing that using it maybe or
you got had access for another use but
the word is that some God some are I
mean I think it's not a bad idea to do
it but that's up to the doctors but
there is a a theory going around that in
our country and some other countries
people are taking that work in the
hospitals that work with the patients
shot left literally from Sean Hannity's
and again it's gonna have to be proven
it's very early you know we're rushing
this stuff through it was this was
supposed to take a long time to be
approved and I prevailed upon the FDA to
get it approved immediately on the basis
that it was already in the market for a
lot of years for another years malaria
mostly and arthritis but mostly malaria
so we'll see what happens but there is a
theory out there that for the medical
worker doctor it may work and if you
take it it's you know it's been out
there for a long time please go ahead
to go back to Jim's question about the
national stockpile but the governor and
I could tell which the stricken
stockpile governor of Connecticut is
today said that he was disturbed to
learn that the stockpile was now empty
that's his words and he said well it's
that empty let me explain something what
we doing I thought I said it accurately
I certainly meant to rather than having
it brought into the stockpile where
appropriate other than certain things
like we have quite a few of the
ventilators which is not a lot when you
look at the whole country actually it
sounds like a lot almost ten thousand
it's not but we're trying to have supply
sent directly to the states because we
save a big state we save a big right we
don't want medical supplies coming in to
warehouses all over the place and then
we take them from there and bring them
to another warehouse so we're having it
brought from the men ideally from the
manufacturer directly to the hospital or
the state where it's going so we're
trying to keep it that way as much as
possible now in some cases we are having
it brought remember this we also took
over a virtually empty and I say it
again like we had no ammunition in the
gallery that's alive virtually no
ammunition that's all I had very little
in medical supplies to in our stockpile
so for the most part we're trying very
hard to have it delivered to the site
where they need it yeah please go ahead
here in the United States domestically
we can practice social distancing but
some of our sailors specifically on the
USS Theodore Roosevelt they're not able
to they're in confined spaces what are
your thoughts on that should they be
offloaded and in sir are you concerned
I'm going to let the military ministers
but are you concerned about US military
readiness during this pandemic for
instance what would happen if if as
reported China was to increase patrols
in the South China Sea
what would your willing to see all about
that don't worry about our military you
know you said the military put up a
hospital in three and a half days with
2009
hundred beds with a lot of bits do you
work has ever seen anything like it and
by the way that wasn't the only one it
wasn't just a Javits Center it was at
other locations and now it's Louisiana
and now it's New Jersey and now it's
other places one thing that I think is
indisputable is when I watched the Army
Corps of Engineers and FEMA working with
them but when I watched the Army Corps
of Engineers throw up these hospitals
and they're complex I mean these are
incredible buildings essentially tents
in various things but they did it in
such a quick such a short period of time
and our military is ready like you
haven't seen and you know the best the
best guests are the different shows are
we watch the shows at night and I think
the best guests that I've seen in a long
time of the military people right and
they've never done it before
I've watched General Semin it-- who I
deal with a lot and I say generally you
got to give us two new hospitals in
Louisiana yes sir
and next morning they're building them
at six o'clock in the morning and
they're up in two three days I think
they're the best the best guests you
have I guess I'm tired of the other
guests at all Affairs Trump didn't need
to tell us he's watching TV every night
we knew that this may be an
uncomfortable question but what would
the models have look like that dr. Burks
and doctor that shows if we started the
social distancing guidelines sooner in
February or January when China South
Korea worth doing this work I'm gonna
let that man you know what information
we're getting from them but if we get
started these practices sooner nasty
people to be dead I'm gonna let him
answer the question but remember this
and again I say it and everybody says it
you know it says it better than anybody
is doctor foul chief I had a decision to
make
right it was my biggest decision China
was heavily infected and thousands and
thousands of people were coming from
China to the United States but felching
against the wishes not even wishes but
they disagreed with the decision I made
a decision to stop China from coming in
took a lot of heat even from China they
weren't exactly happy I just made a
trade deal a big one two hundred and
fifty billion dollar trade deal and I'm
shortly thereafter saying you can't come
into our
country that was a big decision that was
earlier than the date you're talking
about so that was a big decision that
was probably and by the way not because
I did it that was probably the biggest
decision we made so far but if you look
at the one graph the problem New York
has is New York started late but the
other ones didn't start so late question
is what would the curve look like if we
start at six weeks earlier business but
it got a late start but do you want to
cuz I wanted to explain two things that
I think it's really important because we
had a lot of questions about mortality
and what it meant this is where we have
the ability to push it down so you have
a large confidence interval around the
line and so we're trying to move that
grade down tighter and below the dotted
line so I think that's really important
and then if you can go to the next slide
so we really can't answer your question
until we can get antibody testing out
there because what we can't tell you is
in and we can always do this there's
always samples in hospitals and other
things it's the way we really defined
the HIV epidemic in the United States we
were able to go back to blood samples
when we have the test and really find
out where this is an answerable question
she's lying here and really see was
there virus significantly circulating in
early March and ER in late February and
what did it look like and where was it
and was it all in the metro areas and I
think that's what dr. Fauci and I are
very very focused on is getting serology
testing out there to really figure out
when it came and really have those
samples to be able to do that
the painful part of my question and
please I don't mean to put you on the
show again saying if we extorted the
sooner we might not have a hundred
thousand to two hundred thousand
Americans dying well that makes an
assumption there was a lot back here
that we didn't see and until we had the
antibody test I can't really answer that
just underscore with what dr. Burks was
saying if there was no virus in the
background there was nothing to mitigate
if there was virus there that we didn't
know about then the answer to your
question is probably yes now the only
trouble with that is that whenever you
come out and say something like that it
always becomes almost asan sound bite
that gets taken out of context but I
think that's very important what dr.
Burks has said is that if there was
Kolbert infections here that we didn't
know about there was virtually nothing
there then there's nothing tonight I
don't know the answer to the question
but we were watching South Korea excuse
me in China and Italy and we weren't
taking action though you remember we in
South Korea got the first confirmed case
on the same day they've had under 200
people died going on there we didn't but
I believe Jim that we reacted very very
early event medical testing
can I can I speak that too as well oh
boy
president made reference in fact January
31 yeah he suspended all travel from
China shortly thereafter we issued
strong travel advisories for the
sections of Italy implicated and
sections of South Korea and we reached
agreements with those countries to
screen all passengers from all airports
coming into the United States of America
the screen means fever and questions and
remember 20% of people are asymptomatic
being the corona virus from coming into
the United States and what our experts
have told us again and again at the
corona virus task force is that those
actions bought us a significant amount
of time on this curve to respond with
the kind of mitigation efforts standing
up resources testing and supplies that
are in effect but we we went from a
prevention strategy the president acted
on before the month of January was over
to a mitigation strategy which continues
to this day and and if I can also say
just just to every American all the
questions about resources are very
important and I've been well sure you
that the president and our task force
are preoccupied with these issues and
working with governor's hour by hour to
meet those needs non-sequitur if
Americans will put into practice these
guidelines for another 30 days they'll
do their part to lower the curve and
save lives most importantly and limit
the burden on our hospitals and our
health care system in the country
significantly and so make no mistake
about it well well we're gonna work our
hearts out leave no stone unturned to
find the resources the masks the
ventilators that we need and we are
going to meet that moment with a full
energy of the American economy and the
whole of the American government the
American people have a role to play in
preserving that medical capacity in a
way that will ensure
people that are caught up in the
coronavirus particularly those that are
vulnerable to the most serious outcomes
which are seniors with serious
underlying health conditions or anyone
with an immunodeficiency have the
resources of sport and the health care
that every American family would want
their loved one to have also think that
we were very smart because we stopped
China we had never done that before you
know we had never closed our borders
before as I read I read other or maybe
that's not right and doctor foul she had
also said that was a it was I think it
was maybe the biggest moment because we
were stopping the source we were
stopping the infection but we also
stopped Europe very shortly thereafter
that was a big decision that was not an
easy decision or 212 with him a long
time before people started stepping
anyway so we stopped China we stopped
Europe we stopped all of Europe and then
ultimately we stopped the UK Ireland yes
how many clinical trial tests
numerically would you like to see before
you put it a stamp of approval on it
because it's okay
that is an FDA decision and it really
depends on a variety of factors but I
would like to see a clinical trial that
has a comparison to something that is
comparable to what it means without the
drug I mean I keep saying it I say it
all the time and I'll say it again it's
a control trial that compares it to
something meaningful when that number of
trials going on not only in the United
States but also in other parts of the
world you know right now it's too early
to make any determination but I just
want to get back to what I've said all
the time
the definitive way that you get an
answer is by doing a randomized
controlled clinical trial you're talking
about the chloroquine is that what
you're talking about it's specifically
for the last question yes there are
trials going on but they're also trials
going on we're trying them on people
that are now that's the trial yeah
that's what Russ a very important
whatever happens around the world we're
watching those trials very closely Mitch
McConnell yeah he said that impeachment
diverted the attention of the government
do you think that in any way this was
happening and building at the same time
did it divert your attention or your
team's attention or the vice president's
attention well I don't like to think I
did I think I handle it very well but I
guess it probably did I mean I got
impeached I think you know I certainly
devoted a little time to thinking about
it right uh-huh
so but think of it it was a hoax it was
a total hoax right now when you think
that I got impeached only because they
had a majority in the House they didn't
get your ego then you get one Republican
vote well 100 you got acquitted because
you've got a majority in the Senate not
one Republican step I don't think it's
ever happened the Republicans stuck
together and they stuck together in the
Senate 52 to a half a half so you know
when you say that yeah I think it took a
lot of I see them going and saying about
speed well they yeah yeah yeah it was
because of impeachment that I didn't do
anything in January and
today with what happened the horrible
things nobody cares about that now
because all they're thinking about is
the virus and that's okay with me but
you look at the report that came out
from IG Horowitz it's disgraceful what
went on it's disgraceful it's a total
disgrace they got caught in the act but
but you know what horrible we won't talk
about that now
did it divert my attention I think I'm
getting a pluses for the way I handled
myself during a phony impeachment okay
it was a hoax but certainly I guess I
thought of it right and I think I
probably acted I don't think I would
have done any better had I not been
impeached oh okay and I think that's a
great tribute to something maybe it's a
tribute to me but I don't think I would
have acted any differently or I don't
think I would have acted any faster but
Democrats the whole the whole life the
whole being their whole existence was to
try and get me out of office any way
they can
this is an appropriate a phony deal and
it was a phony deal and it turned out
and all you have to do is look today at
the FBI reports take a look at what the
FBI did take a look at the people take a
look at commis report 78 pages of total
kill um cringe take a look at that take
a look at the reporter and McCabe just
read it and you'll see how horrible it
was and you know what I don't think this
country is gonna take it you want to
know the truth
to make is there was hard to take you
what evidence are you offering to
Florida when it comes to the to Holland
American cruise ships that are seeking
to dock here yeah well I'll be speaking
I'm gonna be effect he has a call in to
me will be speaking to will be speaking
to the governor and will be speaking to
him soon but they'll shut it down we
have two ships there are people that are
sick in the ship and we don't want to be
like they're gonna be ghost ships you
know people turn those ships away there
was a ship as you know in a certain part
of Asia and from port to fort nobody
would take it but in the meantime you
have people that are dying on the ship
or at least very sick but they're dying
on the ship so I'm gonna out of it you
know I'm gonna do what's right not only
for us but for Humanity I mean these are
two big ships and they have a lot of
very sick people and I'll be speaking to
I'll be speaking to the governor let's
do just a couple of more back here but I
have nothing else to do so if you want
to I mean if you want so we keep it
going John I think Andrew Cuomo today
said that the system that you have where
governors are a bit trying to get
ventilators it's like being on eBay with
50 other states bidding on a ventilator
and then you just said tonight he was
complaining I say yeah what did you say
exactly what are you saying that when
you have States competing for
ventilators and medical parents it's
like being on eBay with 50 other states
being honored that's all I know well he
shouldn't be complaining because we gave
him a lot of ventilators and if you take
a look at the chart it's down but I wish
he'd got going a little bit sooner but
we gave him a lot of ventilators and you
know what he has a lot of ventilators
right the problem is with some people no
matter what you give it's never enough
it's never enough from sound that in
some of his vision and you're a Democrat
some of them said really good
I'll take gavin newsom from california
who's doing a good job by the way and
others said really good but you know
generally your natural reflex honey
anyone who says Trump's doing okay with
this Trump says they're doing a good job
that's all it is we don't like it oh
really you don't like it we're getting
very high marks but I'm not doing this
for Marx I'm doing this to save lives
when John acted wait when John saw the
numbers and when Jim saw those numbers
they're shocking numbers you know you're
talking about deaths even at the low end
you were shocked when you see a hundred
and a hundred and twenty thousand and
two hundred thousand people over a
potentially a very short period of time
I want to save lives I'm not doing this
for any other reason I want to save
lives but that the Governor of New
York's gotten I think maybe you've
probably gotten more than anybody's
gotten for hospitals he's gotten for
medical tents he's gotten a ship the
likes of which nobody's ever seen before
other than Los Angeles which has the
twin right I mean we've done a lot but
many ventilators were sent to New York
and mayor de Blasio I'm getting along
with mayor de Blasio great and I think
he's very happy with the job we're doing
- we're sending a lot of actually mayor
de Blasio had an interesting request he
wanted people and we're sending medical
people you know a lot of people a lot of
the states aren't having a problem with
ventilates having a problem getting
medical people foul cheese trying to
stay still enough that he might blend
into the background very talented people
[Music]
your response to that question earlier
was that they shouldn't be doing that if
they need something well well if I'm
doing what should be competing and they
should call us wait no I don't want em
to compete because all they're gonna do
is drive up the price I don't want em to
compete they should be calling us and we
can work it so they get the ventilators
and they get shipped directly if they're
competing if they're calling even if
there's only two of them calling they're
going to just drive up the price because
as nice as some of the people that do
ventilators they do want to make money
okay
now you know you don't get a chance to
buy 16,000 ventilators I guess they
didn't take that option that was in 2016
and that's a hard option to take because
it's a lot of money and who would ever
think you need 16,000 ventilators who
would ever think it pandemics prepared
it's a very uni air time and in life and
I think you know I'm dealing with New
York and we're having a very good
relationship and you see what just
happened in Central Park with the tents
I mean we're having a really good
relationship going
you mentioned Japanese done in the job
this is doing I'm interested in what you
think California has done to contribute
to the now let's see what happens
because we could have a spike doctors I
mean you don't know they could have a
spike where all of a sudden its spikes
upward we had a couple like Louisiana I
think they're doing a really good job
but they had nothing now they had Mardi
Gras and then all of a sudden after
Mardi Gras which tells you about
distance saying I guess I mean it's a
it's an example of what could happen but
they were like flawless I was always
surprised I was looking at Louisiana and
I understand that state I love that
state you know and I'm saying they're in
great shape then they have Mardi Gras
was a big success
tremendous success and then all of a
sudden it went like a rocket ship so
that tells you about distance I release
this are you concerned about
in California because I know California
officials like wildfire obviously
there's a homelessness crisis wildfire I
don't know that I'd use that analogy in
California necessarily that very
strongly and I know that it's it bothers
Gavin I don't know if it bothers Nancy
Pelosi but she's got it in her district
at a very high level they have to be
very careful they have a very big
homeless population in an area which
just a few years ago didn't have anybody
in those areas that's not true and
they're living in the streets and
they're I know that some people in
California are working on that very hard
mr. president you start several times
with Prime Minister Trudeau a president
not crawl and at the end of last week
president macro talked about an
important initiative that you and him
would launch any news on that though
we're talking about I don't know who
that reporter is but I love that guy for
the world if we do it we'll see if we do
it or not well I don't want to talk it's
a private thing but it will become
public if we decide to do it but
positive our relationship with the
president our relationship with France
is you know I think extraordinary very
good probably as good as it's ever been
your comments about what could have
happened the actions that you took is
there any fairness to the criticism that
you may have lulled Americans into a
false sense of security when you were
saying things like it's going to go away
what is and that sort of thing but Jim
it's going when you were in it and if
not it hopefully will be soon after that
when they asked him this stuff they
should say when you said we have 15
cases and it's gonna be zero that's the
quote my attitude was that we have to
give this country I know how bad it was
all you have to do is look at what was
going on in China it was devastation and
well yeah you look at the numbers from
China those initial numbers coming out
from China but you know I read an
article today which was very interesting
they say we wish president Trump would
give more bad news
get bad news
I'm not about bad news I want to get
people hope I want to get people a
feeling that we all have a chance I mean
when you suck when you saw the numbers
and when John and all you saw those
numbers and you're saying 120,000 people
you mean that's good 100 now dead people
within a short period of time I want to
give people a feeling of hope I could be
very negative I could say wait a minute
those numbers are terrible this is going
to be horrible this is a horrible thing
hey Jim okay let's go to the beach let's
go to the airport let's go down to Mardi
Gras well there were lots people there
were a lot of people that could have
said that we didn't say that
fortunately I didn't say that and that
was an alternative we talked about it
that was always let it random
that's what I said let it rip let it
ride do nothing and we could have had
two point two million dead people more
than that because I didn't do that and
we did catch it early and we stopped
China really early and we stopped Europe
really early because I saw what was
happening what what happened is I
stopped Italy because Italy was really
heavily infected right we started off
with certain parts of Italy then all of
Italy then we saw Spain then I said stop
you're a blood stop Europe we have to
stop them from coming here Europe I love
Europe but they were having problems I
don't think anybody did a better job
than that especially when you see the
2.2 million number and I hope we're
gonna be substantially under the numbers
if you're looking at on the minimum side
then I think we will have hey look it's
still tremendous death it would
dissipate this would I want to be
positive I don't want to be negative
right I have to I'm a positive person
somebody said oh I wish you'd be more
negative they literally have that send
one of the wonderful news papers today I
wish you'd be more negative well this is
really easy to be negative about but I
want to give people hope too
you know I'm a cheerleader for the
country when I'm through the worst thing
that the country's probably ever seen
look we had
the Civil War we lost 600,000 people
right here's the thing had we not done
anything we would have lost many times
that but we did something so it's gonna
be hopefully way under that but you know
we lose more here potentially than you
lose in world wars as a country so
there's nothing positive there's nothing
great about it but I want to give people
in this country hope I think it's very
important to the severe when you were
saying this is I I knew everything I
knew it could be horrible and I knew he
was lying okay all right let's don't
forget at that time people didn't know
that much about it even the experts we
were talking about it we didn't know
where it was going
we saw China but that was it maybe it
would have stopped at China we wish we
could have killed it in China but it
didn't happen it started spreading to
Europe it's talking so he was lying
I started spreading all over but and I'm
not blaming anybody I'm just saying that
we have an incredible thing I think the
people are professionals our military
our governor's our politicians I think
they've done an incredible job I mean
with few exceptions I think they've done
an incredible job but I don't want to be
a negative person it'd be so much easier
for me to come up say we have bad news
we're gonna lose 220,000 people and it's
gonna happen over the next few weeks and
with that I did start off by saying
today long before this question they
said this is gonna be a rough two or
three weeks this is gonna be one of the
roughest two or three weeks we've ever
had in our country we're gonna lose
thousands of people when I see 28 29
people from the governor of New Jersey
29 people when you see a hundred and
seventy three people died in New York
yesterday or whatever the number was I
think was more than that when you see
the kind of numbers that we're
witnessing we've never seen numbers like
that so it's easy to be negative and
then everybody can be negative but I'm a
cheerleader for our country and I wanted
to do a great job that upper lips
getting sweaty I think you should wrap
said it I want as few a number of people
to die as possible and that's all we're
working on
like a question but are you now taking
regulation do you mom I think it's
actually I think it's things it's not
meant to be look I know you well enough
so it's not meant to be a fair question
but it is a fair question I think we've
done a fantastic job okay fine I'll
accept your word look Jim I think we've
done a great job we're gonna see how it
comes out but when you look at minimal
numbers of a hundred and twenty thousand
people when you look at it could have
been 2.2 million people died and more if
we did nothing if we just did nothing
would have gone up and would have come
down as per your statement it would have
been confined it would have been a
similar time maybe even less time it
would have been a violence like we've
never seen in this country before we had
great professionals great military
really great governors and politicians I
cannot say enough about what's going on
and as per what you said I think we're
way ahead of schedule in terms of
numbers I think I hope but if we can
keep it under the minimum numbers the
country has did not meet the country has
done a great job but I think I've done a
really good job of mobilizing I think
Mike Pence has been fantastic I put him
in charge of the task force we have
wonderful people on the task force Jim
wonderful pastor this man was working
literally he had days where he didn't go
to bed he didn't go to sleep he called
he went 24 hours and then started the
next day people don't know the job he
did I didn't even know he was that good
of a manager to be honest with you Mike
okay and you know you never know that
about somebody until they're tested on
the fire but he saw it very early also
we booked it they saw it very early they
knew pretty soon they probably knew
sooner than anybody because that's what
they study that's what they do
must be a depressing business right must
be a little bit depressing but they've
said they've seen it all go ahead you
dr. gotcha question about a headline
that's been running all day to get his
perspective on it there is a professor
from MIT dr. pouchy who suggested Corona
by
to be carried on droplets a distance of
27 feet do you buy into that and if that
might be the case does that suggest that
current social distancing guidelines may
need to be extended this could really be
terribly misleading John what it was
was looking at the distance that
droplets fly by speaking by coughing or
sneezing so if you go way back and go on
and go like that you might get 27 feet
but so you see somebody do that get out
of the way but that's not practical that
is not practical John I I'm sorry but I
was disturbed by that report course
that's misleading that means that all of
a sudden the six foot thing doesn't work
that is a very very robust vigorous
ah-choo sneeze that's what that is and
that's not all so I think it would
involve probably you know like it may be
outdoor I don't know there's gotta be
something else under normal
circumstances what you would have at 27
feet away would be almost zero Billy
Graham was a trusted spiritual adviser
and friend of many presidents a lot of
your predecessors and times of national
emergency reached out to pastors and
other spiritual counselors have you done
that during this national abroad I never
say that but Franklin Graham is somebody
that's very special I have many very
special people and very many special in
the evangelical evangelical Christian
community you could talk rabbis you can
talk a lot of you know I have tremendous
support from religious leaders yeah and
Franklin Graham I just spoke to him
today for an extended period of time I
told him what a fantastic job you do it
and he does I see what I was doing it he
loves helping people and he loves Jesus
that I can tell you he loves Jesus he's
a great gentleman go ahead a schematic
sir on the mass maybe for the doctor so
what on the mass is the reason why
there's no CDC recommendation
the public to wear masks because they're
meant to to save and preserve the mask
for medical workers or is it because the
virus is not primarily transmitted
through the air so there wasn't ready
see does have recommendations on their
website about mass that came to the
taskforce several weeks ago about if
you're infected wearing a mask to
protect others and if you can't you're
working with someone who's sick and you
have to be that worker in the household
because remember we want people in the
household being taken care of that they
should wear a mask I know your question
is broader than that and it's just being
considered by the task force now about
whether that recommendation that already
exists relevant to wearing masks should
be altered in any way so it's still
under discussion and just about masks
you can get a mask but you can also do I
mean most people have scarfs and scarfs
are very good in a scarf take it off and
what are we talking about a limited
period of time a cape and it says in the
recommendations you can use you can
substitute a scarf for a mask so if
people feel that and I think I'm gonna
wrap a link around I thought people
disagree with the mask for various
reasons and some people don't but you
can wear a scarf you can do the masks if
it makes you feel better we have no
objection to it and some people
recommend it let's go you people never
get tired thank you
to disturb the questions actually mr.
president again I'm looking at the the
cases around the world in Latin America
and the Middle East
one impose it traveled back for these
areas in Brazil for instance the
President Wilson Aarohi keeps on being
very active with groups aren't you
afraid that what we're doing here can be
free giving you people giving you people
not here about me the United States I
mean you're pretty spread out already I
don't have any world but yeah I don't
think we'll have press conferences
anymore but I understand I'm very
careful personally and we are looking at
numerous countries as they get in a
position Brazil as an example you
mentioned the president Brazil had no
problem until just a short time ago and
now they're starting to get inflamed and
yes we are absolutely in a band there
are two other countries you mentioned
Iran already has a band they had sort of
an automatic ban in addition to that
they have a band so we're looking at
certain countries as they become if I
wanted to go to the opening of the of
the hospital in New York and like people
couldn't even believe it
that I said it but I did I wanted to go
they didn't want me to do it the Secret
Service didn't want me to do it for you
know for reasons I want to go to the
boat sailing into New York Harbor but
the governor did a good job of that and
the mayor of New York so you know I'd
love to go out but not be in the White
House and it's sort of like a nerve
center control center and I think it's
important you know look you see what
happened with Boris Johnson you see what
happened with others stay the hell it's
important that I remain healthy yeah I
do so for the most part we're staying
here I've cancelled many different
events and will be staying here for the
most part mr. president uh Tom Frieden
the former director of the CDC
an article the other day in which he
said what's what's really needed here
and you ever see us the work that the
task force is doing is an incident
commander to really take command of
where everything is going and how things
are being coordinated be useful in this
particular instance we have his name is
Pete Gaynor
he's the administrator of FEMA and when
the President signed the national
emergency declaration he stood up the
National Response Center at FEMA and now
I can tell you that when the White House
coronavirus task force meets I'm at one
end of the table and Pete Gaynor and the
whole FEMA team are by videoconference
at the other end of the table and and
that's where whether it be the air
bridge that's literally bringing in
millions of medical supplies from around
the world the thoughtful deployment of
those supplies to hospitals particularly
with regard to ventilators we're working
very closely HHS is fully integrated at
FEMA now but because of the president's
decision to stand up a FEMA in the lead
we have a coronavirus task force at the
White House that's bringing the
president the very best health experts
and recommendations from every agency
but all the implementation as we tell
governor's literally every day is
happening through FEMA it's going down
to the states through FEMA and state
requests are coming up through regional
administrators for FEMA and back to the
White House for this at the same time we
have 4,000 ventilators that are parked
in a warehouse no New Jersey no no no no
but that that was the case we also have
we all we move them out
the question the question is this
happened we also have people not knowing
about the new Abbot testing facility our
testing system if if there were an
incident commander who was in charge of
all of that and getting the word out
would that be a very funny invention
that we just so nobody knew about
nobody knew you could even do it they
did an incredible job this scientist
came up with the idea a week and a half
ago I showed it you yesterday in the box
if I may mr. president I think your
points well-taken the Abbott
Laboratories point of contact test was
approved Friday president announced it
in the Rose Garden on Sunday we're
socializing that all across the
socialite to every governor to
laboratories Ellsworth and and I have to
tell you that this team that the
president has assembled the advisors on
the White House coronavirus task force
and then this team at FEMA whether it be
HHS deputy secretary Bob Catholic who's
coordinating all supplies whether it be
Admiral zihua who is literally working
with every state on a county-by-county
basis to deploy testing is is impressive
and and I think it's given great
encouragement to governor's president I
spoke to governor's in all the states
and territories again yesterday because
governors I can tell you from my own
experience as a governor in Indiana we
had tornadoes and flooding governors
know how to deal with FEMA right and as
soon as the president stood up FEMA
declared that national emergency what
I'll call a certain amount of muscle
memory kicked in in in states around the
country and we're really seeing a
tremendous efficiency and communication
and and that's how we're gonna go
forward again the president's vision
here is FEMA's vision which is in
response to a health crisis it's locally
executed state managed federally
supported and and I have to tell you
we're we're seeing that whole process
spinning up every day and I
I hope Americans looking honor and
by that system and I know they're
hearing from governor's around the
country about the flow of resources and
testing and supplies and we'll continue
to keep that would you call an incident
command what what we call the Federal
Emergency Management Agency working 24/7
all right guys there's mental health
reasons we are at the three hour mark so
I am timing out I think this probably
gives us a sense of today's news we will
be back again tomorrow thanks to
everybody who joined me and a lot of
things happening many of them not good
but we'll be back with you tomorrow